[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right
mike jack what's going on people in the
chat
what's going on arcade what's going on
no vancilia what's up brother
how you doing christopher hart what's
going on let me know how my levels are
sounding
let me know how i'm sounding out here
corey mosley what's going on six slayer
what's going on man what are your video
man
see in the building i see you what's
going on so i gotta respect uh
christopher hart he didn't hear that
podcast and even stopped
yes oh hustling motor forte up in the
audi sleepers
forte
[Music]
from dcx in here got a lot of stuff
we'll have a fun show
you know what i'm saying that's so funny
yo sick i gotta talk to you
on some tv stuff too man a lot of cool
developments i don't know if you quit
that um
the the whole hdmi 2.1 situation on with
ps5 and
uh xbox series x probably discussed that
briefly when we go
live but uh alex psx what's up he said
what up tcl players
yeah we got a little tv talk today it's
gonna be fun you know it's arrow chamber
what's going on man what's going on so
look
be back in a minute let's get the uh
some of them should be coming in i'll
get dcx and king will be rolling up
see y'all in a minute
[Music]
yo said how you gonna expose him like
that he said if at a camera off he's
still raining yeah he was trying to rain
he think he's slick
oh lord daz what's going on what's going
on good to see you brother
then it's it's it's it's hard to expose
people when you took off in like
30 40 minutes after call left but what
are you gonna talk about
anyway see y'all
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
shout out the lord jh with the super
chat i'm trying to figure out your
currency brother
i don't know that so i'm just gonna say
100 but salute to you again thank you
very
much appreciate it we're going to be
live we got lord thor the bill and dcx
in the building
we're following we're waiting for saul
you know what i'm saying we gotta have a
fun show you already know but thanks for
the super chat brother really
appreciation
oh wow thank you what mexican zoey boy
appreciate it with the 100 that's the
first yen i've seen
thank you all right y'all so we're going
to mute and then we will get the king
and everybody in because you know king
will come in with that music and get us
copyright strikes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right jh man thank you brother with
the 100
yen super chat new learning curve to
utilize
directx 12 view features and the devs
are new to this type of innovation
being brought to the trio ms davidia amd
chair salute yeah we definitely gonna
talk about that oh my boy nyt news
just like music okay okay i'll see you
brother yeah we bout to get his kicking
off right in a few minutes man everybody
has arrived the rob's about to start
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
oh my god you're stupid and we
are live welcome to the ireland podcast
and now
live on the lords of gaming.net episode
number 185.
this is another glorious sunday we're
back at the round table on the lord's
day
i'm very excited about our special guest
and we've got playstation 5 multiplied
vs series
x lg oled and xbox partnership
and the game award nominees to discuss
so we're going to get right into it yeah
solve dammit
i want to introduce to the lord whose
unique content was first brought to my
attention by lord king and the amazing
statue community
not only does this law provide a
platform for content creators to
showcase their incredible collections
but with his live unboxings and amazing
giveaways
still finds time to represent the realm
of video game culture
introducing the co-creator and host of
the dcx youtube channel
and friday night open mic podcast
the darth lord of star wars and vader
thomas himself
and the most iconic bulldog you will
ever see on live stream
live from maryland and making his debut
into the realm of the lords
mommy lord thor gizzy gunderson how you
doing sir
it is a pleasant gentleman and we are
honored
we can join you absolute pleasure man
you are a lord and what you do in the
statute community man
happy to have you to rum how's it been
going man what you been up to man
man it's been great i just been hanging
out you know trying to survive the
situation in the world and everything
but uh i'm i'm big fan of you guys man
king it was a blessing truly a blessing
to me king and and it's just uh
you know it's like we known each other
all our lives now man it's crazy and uh
you know we have one every friday night
and i watch you guys
in some capacity every sunday so i
didn't already written down my video
game
oh you know okay
i'm very honored and blessed to be here
appreciate the invite
oh absolute pleasure man we're gonna
have some fun oh shout out to hustling
[ __ ] he said dmv
up in here he threw it he threw up the
dmv quick
yeah he'll be in the building oh qti
grizzly dmv
yo a lot of dmv in the building what
they see okay okay
no no so we're gonna have some fun and
of course you already know we got the
four horsemen of gaming reunited those
original lords are up here at the round
table
my co-host with the co-most my brother
from another mother the difficult game
conqueror
lord of his own world especially in the
rain and the how
of the young wolf lord
deep stone crypt addict look first thing
i want to say
is you've got a deep stone [ __ ]
you can you can say lord of his own
world in the way but
i will i want to point out that it was
right
alex is always right at this point uh
until i am wrong
i am right your reputation precedes
itself sir a lot of
communication issues in this raid
shall we say sir the responsibility of
addict
uh-huh what's up lightly blame other
people but we ain't good
yes you guys yo you guys i know why i
don't play it
it's why this is why you don't play
destiny
movements like this this is yo you guys
are so close to ripping your hair
i would love to see this go down locally
i want to see y'all in the same room
it wouldn't happen like that oh that's
that's the whole
magic of the raid yes because you know
when you're local
you can tell people all right do this
dude let's do that when you
in the raid the level of disrespect
and then some dudes get pissed off when
one like i see attic whole
joint with the last raid that we used to
do right when it was last on xbox before
the
the the great migration the great bike
rack the great ligation is 60 frames per
second
attic was um 100 the lead dude
when it came to these dogs yes right yes
i remember the dogs
some dudes sinister um was not
feeling the the leadership role that was
given to attic at this particular part
in the raid
so it will fall apart all because
one dude felt that he could do what addy
could do and nobody lit
i swear nobody could do what i could do
in that part of the raid
and i gave him so much respect dude just
didn't like me at that point because
i just friended me at that point man the
ray
will test friendships that's all that's
all it is man shout out to slow mo
representing the dmv oh he thought he's
a time there's too much destiny talk
there's nothing happening in that
division oh shots get him yeah yeah
get it to 60 frames per second how about
that let me get this dude
oh uh d geeky nerd um wonder if attic is
going to have that same energy from
crossfire trying to stop console warning
uh in case you ain't noticed we're
talking about games right so uh you know
even him
slandering division that's a game
station we gotta do it like kicks it
anyway
that's how we do it we're going to play
it like kick this one but that's been
pretty much it man we're going to get
back in that rain at some point right
sir
addict yeah yeah yeah i thought you were
talking to someone else no no no that's
good no
and of course returning we have our most
technical gaming lord the solo gamer who
lives for the single-player selfish
experience
and also the south stradabus the lord of
clarity
and lord patreon of the iron bank my man
lord sovereign how are we doing sir
also the lord of bending them knees
i don't know what you talk about once
you know what i decided to draw my knee
so if i i'll take my knee i'll
i'll give you the knee or whatever okay
because um i i know
um i had like i had you over a barrel
and it was something disgusting
and i was just like you know what i said
i
love this dude i'm never gonna do this
to him on here
so i said you know what i'll take the
knee oh wow okay so you're saving your
brother
there were some things that happened
when you were gone so yeah i said
clarify
man of his work
because king came to me with some
damning evidence
it takes defense i was surprised by i
said evidence so i don't know if king
would wrote me the reveal said evidence
but we're never gonna do it okay so we
gonna leave it alone but yeah yeah i was
like okay
i did not know this development so this
we just gonna leave this alone
shout out um slow mo uh backslash
um um if anybody
ever wants to know the real you know um
that's the only place but i'm not going
to
that's my brother so yeah we gotta do it
i need this development development
it's crazy it's crazy it's crazy
take the w i'm gonna take the dough
the craziest thing about it is it's just
like ice it's
literally like he said i'll just like
just like wow
yeah so he walked away
you gotta love that brother man he keeps
him all the way 100. what else we got
there
there we go slow-mo with the follow-up
sometimes the division don't deserve
that slander king haven't you been told
not to speak ill of the dead oh he
called it
this is true that's the truth
i'm gonna walk away from that corpse oh
then we got the
mental all the division people continue
man i'm trying to troubleshoot my damn
dysfunctional system y'all
easy on that division earlier
man we got lying we got a lot of dmv in
the building today i like this one they
out here man
for vader yeah
that's anyway so what's up man you been
offered everything but um
how you been man good man my apologies
for not being here next week i really
wanted to be here but uh i
purchased a vehicle and i had too much
bs running around dude it's just too
much oh congratulations congratulations
thank you welcome to the land of the
driving
let's go so so that was a royal pain in
rio to handle that so i apologize i also
apologize to everybody that i have uh
ghosted on on dms on twitter i will
handle all of that today i'm off today
so
after the show i will handle everything
um you have days off
yes yeah i have all of next week off at
least from one of my justices
that's what they say until they call
them mm-hmm exactly do they call me i'm
off until they call it
any game sir any games ah finally yes i
have to have to get my
my bars off last week so yes i got my
systems first off
shout outs shout outs have to go out
first off to lord
lord james janssen lord zachary
and lord addict uh with the extra
council pre-order in order for me to get
mine because big shout out to amazon for
being the bar none worst
and taking pre-orders they could did not
have a chance in hell or fulfilling
um so i got the yeah i got the email of
death like literally hours before the
launch of the xbox
and then yeah it may be maybe december
31st right
so then i was kind of stuck between a
rock and a hard place i could not go
anywhere to pick it up because i was
still at work
and i'm not really built for 15-hour
marathons outside of
shout out to zachary and then what
addict did afterwards to make sure i got
it the following day
was an extra step above so let it be
decreed here today
the addict can say whatever he wants
about it it's officially adam's work
i just got to do stuff like that to make
addicts more the real thing
okay i i have to i haven't absolutely
want to say about
as well then you know that we then we
have to do the next one after that i
can't i understand that i like it okay
you want the new
okay you get the new name so sorry i'm
sorry
i gamed on that um um the xbox to me
in terms of like just the fluid
transition to the next giant
pretty pretty excellent yeah i haven't
had much issues with it uh the only
issue i had it was the same when you had
cog with the slow downloads
yes and apparently it was something with
the with the the handshake for the nas
like sometimes it would go to moderate
because you know when you download
something and you're playing something
it throttles the download
right yeah so what happens is but when
you stop playing the game and within a
couple of seconds
so that handshake wasn't unhandshaking
so
it continued to throttle even after you
stopped it so
it was the stuff with the instagram but
it seems to work xbox for it
my question um and i asked this to
everybody that you know that started up
the xbox and they went from uh
you know because i know you went from an
x to an x uh series x
uh question um how was the process for
you
uh like when they told you because they
gave you that little door
knob hangar thingy and i know you picked
up and you looked at your app he was
like oh okay what's this
and you did that how was that process
for you just
that little process it was 20 seconds
yeah it was yeah it was
it was 20 seconds and it's like yeah
you're on you're good you're good
all your stuff was there everything was
there just transfer your stuff
that's on your hard drive so one thing
that i did that messed me up a little
bit
i was trying to get ahead of the game i
was like let me download the series x
let me download the base games right and
then move them over and say the same
thing
download the
so thankfully i haven't had any issues
that anyone else has had with either of
my consoles so thankfully um so on the
on the playstation side yes
yes my other means did not come through
as a matter of fact right now i'm in the
process of uh
uh yes i have a case open with
with ebay because you know some people
want to be shady
so once again my fun was trying to be
folded and i was not
having that right so uh you know i
i work very hard so that co-worker he
spent
a lot of money
to get me a playstation the following
day i i
i did it i was you know i'm not even mad
at this we ain't even talking about the
xbox one
the exorbitant amounts of money i spent
in order to have my fun
where'd you watch your foot exactly i
feel i don't know
so i did that um like i said thankfully
i have not had any issues with my
playstation
uh knock on wood i did not get i
i got the digital version which it's a
monolith unto itself
but it is sleeker and prettier than
really the
the yeah the then the herniated ones you
guys got like that that's that
the herniated one dislocated this one
i'm telling y'all um
because it looks like you know what it
is it looks like they built the system
right
and then at the end of the design dock
they were like oops we forgot the hard
drive we've got
we got this driver like it's funny that
you say that spawn wave took it apart
and he said that's not connected to
anything
nine times out of ten that was put there
at the last minute and that's why it's
not part of the design and it's just
thrown in there
wow i don't trust sony anyway so i'm
always looking for a little guy
because a lot of a lot of the issues
i've been seeing people it
it is the disk drive version right so uh
thankfully
nothing yet um i played uh astros
playroom that is
fantastic i'll get into it miles is
fantastic and
demon soul is a kick in my rear but it's
how was the process when you was um
transferring your stuff over and you was
getting that stuff up and running
playstation 5. before i knew see because
i'm on playstation more than you guys so
i knew i knew about the cloud transfers
so i
uploaded all of my saves to the cloud
appreciate the heads up man
yeah guys it's not an automatic song
you know i have to start that game for
the third time which one ghost
persona five
good thing i don't play anything over
there so i can just go back
so yeah i did that and that was i mean
it was fairly smooth once you have it up
in the cloud
um my apologies i did not know this was
the thing that wasn't
known yes yes no it wasn't we're from
the xbox we we
thought this was automatically on the
xbox you know we you know the wildest
thing
the wildest thing i still can't log into
my playstation um
i i heard through reddit that uh it was
a
playstation that got hit they got ddos
uh that week
and a lot of people emails got changed
around oh so
i was like oh boy oh brother put that
two-factor authentication sir
yeah well um somebody had asked me that
too well i'm never over there
i'm just like man okay so they got to go
through my
um my playstation id which is uh for
anybody that likes to play
with me over on playstation 360.
thank you for your yeah i heard you
weren't
i heard they weren't feeling that when
you tried to like no i don't think i
think that's it i think they trying to
blackball me
anyway so we gotta give you some chances
so that was that that was that um so far
knock on wood no issues with both
systems so i'm happy
we've got times which we got we've got
suicide with the 10 super chat sup chats
up lord soft king scourge bringer stop
sleeping on it
king i get that sankocho yeah
delicious delicious yeah i was late
we have gay before today with the five
dollars super chat sounded like a person
that got bodied in destiny tv
brother all loved bro
can you say how much you hate it that's
the the king was like you should just
say that you just not that good
on demonstrations
i'm watching um season gaming right now
on uh demon souls
that's what's up yeah aims too yeah
salute
um we have darion craigo with the five
dollar super chat why are people acting
like we haven't had these consoles for
only two weeks
we have seven plus years to go you know
you know
you know you look at the playstation uh
five pro next year
oh no moving so that's it
of course we have the incredible hulk of
this aka
the access gamer oh the prophet
of xbox king of the statues who has
nothing less than that premium
experience
it is the leader of the fraud alert
movement
beloved lord king how we doing sir i'm
doing still sick
um shout out to the persistent cough ah
so you see myself mute myself
but um if you guys did not uh see my
story about craving the hunter
that's that statue right there that's xm
studios craving the hunter
with the biggest lion in the business um
go see it yes uh watch the video uh even
if you're not a craving a hunter fan
the story is so chilling and
and i'm i just give you a synapsis right
because
the actual story is far worse
than i reported because i have to walk
the fine line
because we have children watching yeah
so i have to walk the fine line
of giving you something family-friendly
that book is so chilling and it should
have came with an r
rating on the book because there's a lot
of uh
possession it's a lot of uh mental
illness
throughout the book that i don't touch
on but trust me when i tell you that
book is so
serious it is probably one of
spider-man's greatest stories
ever told and it illustrates
why craving a hunter should be the most
feared
character that he ever came across
because i don't think a character
went to that depths to do what he did
um okay and i love the musical choices
sir it's very cool thank you very much
very tribal
i was definitely feeling the aesthetic i
was i was there in the jungle with
crawford
thank you thank you because in my head i
saw a craving like peeking through yeah
i'm playing right now star renegades
okay
and i'm playing river city girl oh yeah
yo
tell me yes what's the tell me that
river city girl this way hold on
city ransom is this one yes okay yeah of
course
game pass baby
oh my god you crazy phil still dominus
maximus are really a spencers that
definitely did this for me
so river city girls mm-hmm
i know saab was going to love this
because river city ransom was our joint
right so um river city girls
they talk throughout the whole
joint um there's a side-scrolling beat
em up
couch co-op local throwback old school
yeah
it's completely old school nice but they
have the
music music the music is
rocking it's animation heaven if you
like what was that game um
uh the pilgrims scott pilgrim mm-hmm
if you come back scott pilgrim
you're going to love this game
and star renegades is uh um
it's a rpg uh slash strategy game
real time and uh but it also is
turn-based
um beautiful these games
couldn't be done in the past and i'm
starting to realize this 16-bit era
yeah is finally being realized now the
way it's supposed to yeah a lot of these
retro joists is really hitting it
beautiful stuff facts facts you know
shout out to um hustle he said yeah he
said it's fire let's get the super chess
off we got a squirrely uh we got
squirrely down with the fight off so we
chat the only problem i have with my ex
is when i shut it off it turns itself
back on and freeze it
i have to hard shut off before i can use
it normally oh no yeah i mean there's
still been issues with
like at first i had it in the um the
regular sleep mode right
and that was that wasn't in order to
reset that handshake so i wouldn't have
those slow down lows the problem is that
you don't get
downloads while it's in in that sleep
mode you don't get any updates
you know what i feel like is the issue
first thing i want to say is definitely
go
uh you know watch those statue videos by
king
i wanted to say something but uh king
was talking like the thing i appreciate
the most about that is i don't know
nothing about comic books
at all so when i listen to it
i'm like oh that's where this dude
belongs to because you always see
these people on like twitter on facebook
but you have no idea where yeah
there'd be times like yeah shot the kid
cause it'd be times where i don't
really i think i know about the
character and then he'll do his synopsis
with the statue
and i'm like yo i never knew that and
this person's history goes deeper than
what i thought but yeah salutes a little
continue
get that song um yeah we then we have
gerald mack
with the fight off super chat welcome
back saab thank you sir finally the
entire team back in the building shout
out to the parts
enjoy next gen looking forward to next
year yeah
then we got shroom kingdom with the five
dollar super chat sony's not letting
king sign in because of the card reader
hashtag swipe your call i'm done
yeah go go go try to play avengers
mm-hmm
that's crazy pretty much that's it those
two games
okay oh and destiny of course of course
of course of course of course you know
but
i have to be in invisible mode because a
lot of people like to just
jump in me my my party's paws jumping my
my
my parties and just be like yo you're
king so listen back to what i was saying
i was like what remember when the rabbit
monkeys was running
random conversations yes people like how
i felt the monkey should have been doing
it
i would have been doing it this way i'm
like oh oh man
you can't even play it face the price of
starters being the king that's the price
you pay man
anything and of course we got the gaming
ninja himself the shinobi lord cognito
unlocked spreading that realism around
the iop not telling what you want to
hear but what you need to hear
yo do me a favor y'all i know i always
promote last word y'all know i'm destiny
hardcore hardcore dog but please if
there's anyone
that i would appreciate you guys
watching i'd never ask
is this one because we had skye lewin
and again even if you don't care about
destiny
this guy has been a musical editor for
popular tv shows
entourage csi miami fargo
you know remember the karate kid remake
with uh yeah what you call it he did the
score
i mean he's done if you don't like that
he done halo he was
they brought him in on halo reach odst
and then he's been
the composer on so far back yeah
he started off the drums the drama if
you like the drum
that's my man that's him that's yo
please salute
skye get get out there it's up on the
iowa podcast channel
we did interview from again he works
with bungie and it was an absolute
pleasure
definitely proud of the interview would
like to get a little bit of support
because it was a very hard interview to
get so if you can support it
we much appreciate it man but yeah
salute to sky
it was lit unarmed yeah man we did
obviously i had to talk about we did the
raid
we're all trying to on the world first
watch the communication breakdown watch
friends argue with friends and
all that good stuff but that's part of
the real [ __ ]
okay i didn't do the 24-hour get busy
yeah yeah we still like contest mode
it's good it's going to be a situation
that once you get out of it
i don't like to find out nothing i like
to get there and then
people are telling me yo all right so
are we going to throw the ball in here
you stand over here
tell me what to do yeah make sure that
you hold down this rock if
somebody come in this room punch them in
the back of the head i'm like okay cool
i got that
i got that i know my role i know my role
all that figuring it out and we dying a
million times
game over bro i will say the first i
hated the way it really started because
i i was terrible at it i was holding the
team up i was like
folding the raid they were they were so
nice to me because they knew i couldn't
drive a sparrow in the snow with no
clearing
and they were just like all right let's
go go back somebody go back and get
caught
they had to stop the rain they're like
yo find him where is he out here in the
wilderness
i went back for cognito and then i got
then they got low score to get me
so i just didn't like the first
encounter because i just felt and then
we got lost that's the only thing like
the first thing
i have to spoil too much whatever but
the first account is just too long
and a little too extra to start off a
raid and on your sparrow
in the cold antarctica you can't see the
visibility i'm like come on and you're
getting frostbite
and if you don't find these hot zones
you're gonna die like it's crazy
it's crazy so salute to that but other
than other than that
once we got going it was cool to see
some problem solving and us
trying to come together as a team but
anyway enough of that so look man we got
some royalty in the stream
cheat sheets did we
is in game pass also craven will watch
uh before mt's hit overnight
also ufc sneaky good bullet got some
good slams also no destiny
salute for the message look we're going
to get into we have special guests in
the round so now that we got into what
the lords have been playing
i want to focus on lord thor aka
vader diamonds himself his video game
system history
his journey into the statue community
and of course what led him
to create the dcx youtube channel and
that friday night special
open mic so let's start from the very
beginning man like what was some of the
first
video game systems you had what got you
into gaming man i'm gonna tell you i
i started i didn't have it my god
brother i go all the way back to me and
television
wow my god brother he had in television
and uh the craziest thing but i think
coming onto this show i was thinking
about the craziest thing about the
television
was the controller like the controller
literally looked like a dial pad on the
phone
and it had like you know and then but
the actual controller was like a disc
you had to just push on the disc
and each game that you played had like
an overlay you put into the dial
yeah it was crazy man and then um i mean
my favorite
game my favorite game was dungeons and
dragons and you go
you go find these snake and a dragon and
go get the treasure
and it was crazy you know we think about
it now it's like you know i used to play
i used to get hyped over this man
but it was it was tight back in the day
and so then
i got a uh my first system was nes
and um that was i would never forget
that christmas yes because my mother
used to date some guy to work for
popeyes
shout out to probably he would bring he
would bring a bag of chicken home every
day
and to this day i can't stand papaya
so you know we got zelda and i mean
literally the two weeks i was off from
school for christmas we just
you know going after gannon and
everything and unlocking
it it was great cartridge that gold
cartridge the gold cartridge is right
and then um
you know tyson's punch-out oh let's talk
about it was just
that was like the golden age for me you
know what i mean and uh
then tecmo super bowl came out that game
actually got me through college
you know what i mean because uh we used
to lay money because a friend of mine
before i went to college
he was big time he used to whip me all
the time and he you know eventually said
look man that's what you're doing wrong
you only use these four plays
nobody plays these things is what you
use it's all the rest of their mess
don't eat all these
flickers and all that crap don't worry
but let me ask you what
was the bo jackson was in the building
who was who would you take i used to you
you know what i used to use
yeah uh barry sanders was tight but my
my squad was the giants
the giants was the most balanced team on
it and
and when i got to school it was like i
was just with his training
i would i was whipping everybody then we
was laying money on the line oh
seriously people used to come to my dorm
yo man we want you and then finally the
day came when i lost and
it was crazy how long i lost seven to
six
wow and if you remember you could block
the field goal on that no
right the last play i got close enough
kick a field goal and he blocked it and
that's how i lost
stop and and people was like damn you
finally lost i was like yeah then i just
didn't play after that
one shot these great nds stories i got a
shout out to shout out my brother sting
up original next level gaming
he's giving you a shout out on that in
television even though there's some
coleco guys in here that said coleco was
better
but they said they respected your
intelligence and one thing i wanted to
bring because we don't talk about this
enough game
and remember he's right remember the
overlays i forgot
no i didn't forget about that i hated
that yeah because
it came with two it came with two
controllers
and you know you plugged them in and
they had that wrap around it looked like
a phone cord yes
and yeah you know because he was able to
put it back
inside the the the television
console right and i had coleco vision
two
and colecovision had a different you
know uh style for they joined but
in television always won with the
overlays because whatever game came
you just slid the overlay in and if it
was jump button
press jump right there and it had a
whole visual thing to it
so you know they gave a little bit extra
in the box i thought the television
didn't do that but
we had because it was the one with the
phone with the with the button but there
was like a slide in
and depending on the game because a lot
of these games have button functionality
in the game like one would do this or
each one would have something
and the overlay would kind of tell you
for that specific game
what the functionality is i forgot about
overlays
i mean yeah i don't remember the
overlays for palm yeah
the overlay went on the tv
well that was that was because we had
black and white so
then you put it on the television and
then this side was red versus blue
and um and it had that line in the
middle like
yeah bro shout out to that was that even
480i
at that time no no no no no no no no
i know it's bad because when you go to
record it now and you see those scan
lines
anyway it's back to little though anyway
so boom you got you got nintendo
you're doing the zelda you got the zelda
but then you're stepping it up tecmo
bowl
competitive you're going on so you
stayed at the nes where did you go from
there
it was then it it's kind of a tragic
story somebody broke in me on my
mother's pad and took my nintendo oh
then for some reason i started hanging
with like some of her friends sons and
stuff
and they had sega and they and i was
like oh this is cool it was trash
oh no we can't do that i mean we can't
do that see you it was all good until
you did the slander
but it was like like
on the platform no it was like when i
played zillion
and we called um
the playing game um with chocolates
no no it was like an f-16
yeah and out run and all that stuff but
like yeah but that was
watered down though yeah yeah and the
arcade it was tight
at a young age that's when i had the
master system
that's what i figured out i was like
this ain't exactly like the okay yeah
you learn quickly when you go to arcade
that's not what you played hang on
all right it wasn't you you're right
you're right you're right yeah
was like oh no
[Music]
only thing they had going over nintendo
is they had
cards and cartridges and the system was
more powerful it was more powerful
it was more powerful but you couldn't
tell
i don't know double
[Music]
let's go hit that like button big cloud
playstation in the building what's going
on
we got bret with the two dollar super
chat no sega slander loud absolute words
we're going to let him let him slide
with the sn i mean coming from the nes
he had to go over there we gonna let
that slide but continue so you got the
sega now and
you're frustrated yeah yeah so then
later on
got genesis and jesus and everything and
then uh
rodney your boy rodney came with uh
super nintendo and
that was you know that mean we always
see the dude looking at the chick going
right there
yeah it was like that i mean it was good
but it wasn't that damn good
yeah i mean so you know and he got that
and he when i first watched him play
super mario world and the stuff they had
like that technology where the stuff
could come at the screen in there
seven i was like slim
you know he was like man i told you yeah
and then i got a job that summer and
saved all the money and got one then
street fighter came out oh man
that was like you know you when we was
in high school
street fighter was like the old west
facts like you carried you you carried
your game on your hip like a gun and
it was just people would come i mean all
night long until the sun came up
fast i mean it was like it was crazy
and that that was like a movement that
gave me a little like if somebody ever
said something wrong about your street
fighter when you had it like
like saying like it's not arcade perfect
that dude got punched in his eye right
right ain't nobody ever say that i mean
let me let me tell you something real
quick just real quick
shout out to cog for bringing this
ponyta that's why i can't stand dudes
with ponytails
into the story i cannot stand a dude
with a ponytail grab a chin
[Laughter]
yo i went out and brought this cartridge
it was 250 dollars yes
right it was the japanese nintendo
famicom street fighter
i had it eight months before it came
actually uh
america actually i called cargo but this
is when i was working in a community
center i'm
in the community center i shut off
everything
just me cuz and i told cogs just come
over i got it come on
come from lunch and get over here so he
was going to manhattan center up there
he came down he came in with the
quickness yes i left him in the room
and he come in the room with this dude
with a ponytail
i turned the game on and street fighter
started playing
and he goes yeah but it don't look like
the arcade
i said get out
yo he's gonna beat up my man i'm like oh
come on king like
he almost ain't making it out there
listen we always got them geeky friends
and then i was like look cause i was
showing off you know what i'm saying i'm
going to man center
this is high school days you know i'm
saying shout out to cameron shout out to
maze manhattan said that's where we went
with high school at so king at the
center not too far
you don't see it at harlem so he's like
yo i got
the the street fighter joined early
eight month i'm like yo that's crazy
so i'm gonna come through so my man here
gamer so i was stunned i was like yo
my man got the street fighter he was
like that's that there's no way
the american release is not out i say yo
if you come with me right now
you're gonna see street fighter just
pull up all right cool so he can't
do it so he i think he was mad i think
he was mad that you had it because
he was betting with me like there's no
way steven is just like i'm i'm full of
s you know i'm like nah
so he came through i think that's what
it really was that he was hating
that you had it and that what we were
saying was true so now he got to eat his
word he lost the bet of me
but obviously then you almost didn't
make it out of you
literally i was going to go in the front
and tell horace cause horace was my pit
bull
i was going to tell harvard she'll just
finish this dude off man shout out to
the corner of the block beat him
shout out the king beat dory beating up
my friend anyway moving on
continue you know sending mortal kombats
and stuff
i like mortal kombat not too much of
street fighter though you know what i
mean it was it was tight
but it just street fighter just just
felt like home you know i mean
it just yeah like to this day i could
still perform the dragon punch and
you know everything like it just it just
sticks with you
you know you're like on it you're
absolutely iconic
yeah man iconic sure you can
listen it was a movement even in the
arcade you put that quarter up on that
thing
it was serious like you said wow wild
west continue brother
you definitely definitely take it it did
so street fighter
what else came after that um you know
then nba jam i wasn't too big in the nba
jam
um let me see after that came
playstation that's when uh metal gear
and all that stuff came out and uh that
was that's
that's been my game that was kind of
like a love-hate relationship because
it got to the point after um after like
playstation 2
i started to go to xbox route and i
couldn't and it was killing me
because there was more on xbox than i
wanted on playstation
you know i mean so it was like i i
missed playing metal gear because their
first metal gear
was amazing i played the second one
because i was on playstation 2 but then
like three
i was like dying to play i never to this
day i've never played it because i
didn't have playstation 3.
you know so i got 360. 360.
brought me to the modern age you know
because that was like
my introduction into online yes like i
played socom
on playstation 2 with madden and that
was about it but
i'm i'm thankful for playing socom
because that taught me tactics battle
tactics factual
like you know don't give up your
position and all that kind of stuff
so you was one of those dudes that was
up late at night like two o'clock
two three o'clock in the morning playing
so-called no i'm not that late i mean
i'd play
it was like one crew i'd play with and
for some reason they wanted to play the
same board
and all this it was foxhunt i think it
was called yeah yeah they want to keep
playing and i was like dude let's play
this snowboard and we play all right
let's go back to
you foxhound what i mean but um then 360
came
yeah and then came gears of war oh yeah
and that was
that was literally until the next one
came out ever
before there was friday night open mike
there was friday night fights
we played from eight o'clock at night
and you look over and the sun be coming
up wow
yep you know it was like that and that
that game
i'm kind of mad at them going forward
because people were changing stuff
because they were revolutionizing things
yes right and the people were changing
the way they did stuff to like do to be
like is war
then later on gears was like adapting to
what everybody else was doing and that
pissed me off like
because at the first one there was no
party system and all that kind of stuff
you just played with the same crew and
it was like mad trash wait we just
whooped y'all you know all right we'll
see what happened this time
and then the second one it'd be like you
know they change it up you play somebody
else and all that kind of stuff
but to this day that is for me i mean i
don't know about nobody else
that is my best online experience of
playing going gears of war because
you had to have skills it was no
cheesing it was no
you know because usually nowadays people
like even on squadrons people find a
little stuff they can do
and and you know like camping and all
that kind of crap
you couldn't camp on guests if you
couldn't play we found out we found out
you know what's crazy i feel like in
terms of xbox users
in the beginning like it's neither you
or a halo fan
or a gears like that very few were both
yeah very valuable but
but you got a little thorough you got to
show them the iconic oh yeah i'm real
you kidding me
we we was a squad i don't know oh
oh oh yeah that gear's tight right there
and the whole crew got one except for
riding he didn't get one
but he was like
but uh it was like that man and then uh
then we moved on to uh what was it two
and let me move on but it was like it
got to the point where
we played gears half tonight and then we
played smackdown versus raw 2007.
oh oh my god that was amazing that game
was amazing i made
like it was and it was funny because
once i'd be on there by myself and i i
made my number one
you know you could make wrestlers on
there and everything yeah and i made
this dude who i thought was tight and he
started getting whooped
and this dude one time he was just
laughing he was he was whoopi he's
laughing
i got pissed off and you know i'm a
comic guy too just like king
and then one day i just i just looked
over my books and i saw a picture of
bane that's i'm gonna make bank
and i made bain and then it was like and
i could never i was looking for this
dude i never found him again but
he he spawned everybody
he's full of yo this is amazing man yo
the wrestling gays back in the day
yeah king needs to terrorize us in that
era i forget
no no i used to get my butt whipped he's
lying
okay so what it was he's absolutely
lying because it was him and sovereign
and sovereign on
on certain fighting games on a large
majority of them
he has this knack of finding somebody
that could put you in some death move
that you can't get out of right
this is his knack and this is what he
does it doesn't matter what the game is
he's going to find a character that's
going to do something evil and malicious
to you
and he's going to hold that down well
what they were doing they was playing
wrestling
and i wanted to be a part of the whole
wrestling thing so i didn't know who to
take and stuff
and i was trying to take dudes and i
know my wrestlers and you can't go
who's your popular wrestler right well
these dudes had they joined online and
they was having so much fun
and i was like damn man so one year we
do a draft
right so one year jamie
got i got i got the rock right i won the
rock
and jamie is such the rock fan i knew
the rock was trash in this game
and he had goldberg so i'm such a huge
goldberg fan i said i'll trade you
straight up
bet that was the worst
[Laughter]
that was the trade goldberg that was
like undefeated street
oh my gosh that's when my level of
terror began
yes because i held it all in my chest i
swear they used to beat me mercilessly
all the time but when i got a hold of
goldberg
never lost yeah the only i beat him once
with goldberg and who
created character it was nice it was a
fake character
it was a it was a g character in the
body of uh he who should not be named
the murderer yes yes yes yeah
yeah yeah so
yeah goldberg was too much in it yeah it
was too much it was just ridiculous
i won so many good bets like dudes
having to ride me around on their back
you just have to crawl into your left oh
my god
yeah yes yes the s
talking it was it was crazy like i
it and there was nothing you could be
whipping you could be beating him the
whole match he doing one or two moves
super meters off on fleek a jackhammer
and it's over and i'm like
come on my guy like this is too much i'm
like who who's down with the balance
team
yeah hitting the balance but anyway
moving along we're going we go fast
forward from that
but anyway that's a little bit
tremendous you got that 360. i just
gotta back up just for a second because
i see some amazing arcade units behind
you sir so
oh yeah yeah i got um i got this back in
the arcade days uh star wars obviously
was you know that was one of my favorite
games and uh
they actually dubbed audio from the
movie and everything the one you can't
see i got the uh
marvelous capcom class and uh with the
punisher for rodney and then uh
the main reason i got it was because
x-men children adam that was after
street fighter that was my second
favorite
fighting game because again that was
before they put all them super moves and
stuff in here
and you just had to have skills you know
all this x moves and stuff before they
put that in here you know but
so um yeah so those and i'm waiting for
them
if they ever make wrestle fest
already i got that here so oh yeah he
got it he got he got here yeah whenever
whenever you come down to new york
you can play the original right i need
it very bad
romania i think in january it's the
spiritual successor that
a lot of the guys that like the guys
that are making it are yes
like their favorite thing is is wrestle
fest so you know
you covered that game then we covered
that game yeah
actually got a lot of views really got
like a little bit of footage people keep
asking about that game we covered that
pack
yeah definitely on that but salute oh
man tremendous so again you stayed
through it and then you just rocked out
360 era then kind of cool or just kind
of
peek your head in everything 360. um
oh now i got xbox one
and then um yeah xbox one after that
yeah and man that uh that grand theft
online was amazing
like doing them heist and all that kind
of stuff like the one where you break in
the prisons
yes that thing was serious you know
so i played that for a long time and
then we played what was it um
rainbow six oh yes oh yeah on three
back of a second rainbow six on three
six feet five
vegas vegas yeah i used to call myself
a black beret had this black beret and i
speak french
in the black marine position
yeah that's what we used to do mainly
you know it was a terrorist hunt and uh
that's how we ranked up with playing
terrorism all the time and everything
yeah that game was great
absolutely remember when we saw the
glass breaking technology yes
yes succeeds we were like oh my god oh
my god this is the next level
this is the next level of gaming i
always thought tom clancy did a damn
good job
well whatever his name was on you knew
it was like a certified good product
but you know what you know what i was
kidding we got it we gotta i gotta touch
on it too vegas did a lot of things we
got that
remember they were introducing the voice
tech
breaching glitch yeah get the door oh
yeah and then they would go do it your
man's gonna
go do it off the voice commit that voice
commander was a thing at that time that
was a
like a big gimmick at the time cover
cover that
and you know
xbox remember it's rainbow six yes yes
so so
you got xbox one did you get playstation
4
i got it now but and it's messed up how
that happened you know what i mean
because
i had my uh xbox online
subscription and everything and it was
running out but you know it was taking
it out of my credit card so i said i
don't want to switch you you buy the
card you know the 50
card it wasn't trying to let me do that
wow you know i mean
i don't know it was like i went on there
and it was like yeah your subscriptions
running outside don't put this card and
they was like nah
we're not accepting this we want to keep
you know what's your call
you got to give me your information it
was like so i just let it run out
yeah okay and the reason i gotta play
stage four was because
i want to play god of war i never played
the first
three or whatever right you know they
look cool
but i see i kept seeing stuff for this
boy
i have got to play that game and um
so that's why i got four but uh oh i
just thought another one another
milestone like um
back to 360. mass effect 2.
oh you just literally said the greatest
mass effect
i mean you just literally said amazing
the first one because rodney played the
first one and i didn't like the controls
talk say it louder for the people in the
back about to control
it was the controls that messed one up
for me like the game was legit but it
was like i got halfway through i said i
can't deal with these controls
or two when they had the unreal engine
from gears so you know i was
i was ready for that yeah and man i mean
just and i kept because i kept thinking
about one and again i kept seeing the
trailer i was like man this game looks
tight
and then i heard uh martin sheen oh the
youngin that's martin
luther yeah yeah i said man i got to
play and
and it was so tight with that i would
literally go back to back with the game
like i'd finish it yeah i'll go back
out again do renegade paragon yeah and
like because i could never
and and i kept getting pissed because i
could never get everybody out alive
and but like i finally did it because
like you said yeah you got to either be
straight renegade or straight
good and everything right so finally i
got that done and i still kept playing
i mean that game that was that game was
amazing massive fake
[Music]
that's right only the best mass effect
ever created continue
why don't you read why don't you read
lincoln no we don't need to read that
we're good
he ain't put it didn't put that in color
he put what i like in color
so anyway shout out to oh i am mike
though he just put
me on remember he said vegas was rainbow
six vegas so fire
you could use your 360 camera and put
your face
on your camera
your tremendous video game system
history brother we keep talking about
this
but there's still other aspects of you
that we want to talk about you know what
i'm saying and um
one is like i said the the statue
community and just you know seeing you a
part of it obviously and um
like how did that that whole fever that
whole how did that develop when you like
okay
i'm i'm loving this i need to get into
this it was funny it was how i got into
it um you know don't you always go to
the comic book shop and you see they had
like bowen statues and everything
because you know
you know spoiler my favorite comic book
character is thor you know i mean
i used to be a big spider-man guy but i
think when when like toward the mid to
late 90s
i wasn't liking like the spider-man
books like all that spider island and
all that stuff
i ain't like then um when i got started
working a friend of mine
he got me his man why don't you try this
and the first book i read was thor
versus gladiator
was amazing all right i became
thoughtful anyhow
they had this bowing statue of thor with
like the spinning hammer behind i was
like how did they pull that off
and you know you go through this stage
of man i ain't paying no four hundred
dollars for no statute
you know what i mean that's what
happened he said in the beginning
it's like a mental break it's like a
mental thing at first but then once you
get on the hand you're like
damn
one birthday my mother my mother my wife
uh got me
that statue and when you get it when you
get it and hey you like
wow you know it's even more amazing than
you even imagine
yeah so it was always this darth vader
statue i wanted and i said man i don't
care how much it is
i'm getting it and it's over there y'all
can't see it um
he's he's got his helmet off and he's
holding his helmet he's like looking at
it
that's the and he's thinking about
everything that that he's done to get
him to where he is now
you know and i said i got to have it i
finally got that one and that's when the
boom happened
i need more i need more money more and
then finally here we are
so how we started it was like i took
vietnam statue over with rodney workers
rodney check this out man
and he was afraid man i ain't buying
that stuff and he got looked at he was
like damn
he's a big walking dead fan he bought
like these little walking dead sets but
you know
i don't remember that man what is that
he saw man
i'm gonna collect these that's okay
you know he he pre-ordered that uh the
hulk versus wolverine
you know and he got that and then for
him that was you know now he's
again he's a big punisher fan mm-hmm so
and it was funny because one time they
had these raffles raffles
and um we're going to get into that yeah
i know he won the xm
the excellent punisher and that was like
at the time that was like the best
punisher mm-hmm
and so that's one on bike he won the
one-on-one bike he won that one yeah
it used to be a secret group that that's
not around anymore and uh
wow that statue was a 1200
statue but yeah he wanted flex flags all
i had to do was pay the shipping and
that was it wow and uh so we started
our channel and uh shout out to red
titan they actually gave our uh
uh inspiration for starting our channel
yeah and uh the way
of course the name how the name came
along was uh rodney's a big time
punisher fan his real name
frank castle again our darth vader fan
so we named it darth castle as if it was
the name of the fifth lord
yeah you know so everybody thought it
was you know that was cool i think
five so yeah so then we just thought our
claim the fame started we just did a lot
of live
unboxings you know what i mean and i
mean people don't admit it we were the
first one to do it live
a lot of talk you know so now
everybody's doing it you know
so that's cool and um what we call it uh
red titan they did chats first you know
did the chat thing we always wanted to
do a chat too but like we didn't want to
do the same old thing
so we just let people be who they are
you know no no censorship
and it it just it started off slow then
more and more people like one day i
looked up
like a thousand people watching this
thing i'm like really wow you know and
um
it just it just grew and we also put out
the the
the notion that if you want to whoever
you are you want to join us come join us
that's awesome and all kind of you know
we just had sculptors on and
none of the corporate people will come
on because we're not exactly status quo
you know you know i ain't worried about
it and
i mean i've met so many people like we
went to new york comic con
people that hit me up from like
singapore and all come out watch you
guys all the time and
you got a guy from singapore on just
recently right with it he was a
three-point yeah he he
he and like i've had people actually
messaging this and man you know
y'all have actually y'all humor has
actually got it through hard times and
everything and please keep doing what
you're doing and like you know
stuff like that makes you stop and think
that's all you know i mean like that you
you mean
you know what you're doing you don't
think about it but you mean a lot to
other people
factual you know it helped him get
through so um it was crazy how i blew up
now it's just
what it is today and it's it's funny
because i think also about you know
we're not you know we got about what
1500 subs to
you know and channels out there with
bigger subs and they do their shows and
we do
almost about the same numbers you know
what i mean oh it's like
you know it's amazing you know cog and i
just talked about that whole sub thing
and um you know some dudes do it
organically and some dudes do it
artificially
so um the fact that you know that we do
it organically
um when when you reached out to me i was
so happy to be on because i
yo i was like a school girl
they could tell you they could tell you
he was excited because i was like yo
yo they hit me up they hit me up yeah i
said
i said and i said they were smart about
it because they send the woman
first i was like okay okay they watching
me
they said you know barbara through and
she's like yo you know uh whatever
whatever you want to
come to i was like oh okay all right so
i watched the show and i was like oh i
know these dudes
i said yeah watch these dudes so oh my
god right so
and when i got on
i couldn't stop that that whole day you
know how you got goosebumps the whole
day like i had goosebumps the whole day
and it's if when you
get around people that share your
passion
to your degree or higher
it's it's elating it's it's exhilarating
it's
it's a euphoria that i can't express to
people
all i can say is like i'm home like like
this this is this is what it do
so like last week and i really had to
tell you
thank you so much because on friday
my girls saw the lead-in right because
you know on your youtube
yeah it says you know we're coming up
and coming out i love the way he does
the channel yeah
and he put you know returning to king
yes and fire she was like
that's why because i'd be sometimes i'd
be dead tired
i don't know how the hell you pop up and
you got that energy and you run straight
downstairs
it's because it's genuine
love facts when you come through and
his passion his love like yeah he's
making a statue he he's not telling you
the all yeah he's in the process of
making a statue wow conceptually
and it's being done and the artist is
hitting him back and forth
and showing him the pictures and does
this work
he is deeper and more integral
to the statue community that dudes
really know and i just really wanted to
tip the hat to you
because i said you are absolute pioneer
absolute you and rodney are absolute
pioneers and i just want to give you
your roses while you are here
to let you know how much you impacted me
and i'm pretty sure you impact
thousands of other people that probably
don't want to admit it
yep but they got no choice but to bend
the knee and watch even if they're in
the background
they gotta watch factual man salute i
mean yeah
it's just preventative obviously you
know it's it's a new community
to me and just to see king i seen the
energy
and i remember you hit me he was like yo
i got hit up
like he does it dcx okay you don't say
so i was like okay and i'm watching it
and one thing about you guys that i like
first of all
you're so inclusive right and as long as
they have
passion for the culture they're in
and just hearing you guys store and it's
all it's the thing like it's all over
the world one time it's like a dude in
australia and
this is it's all overweight everybody's
got their cameras on
and the way the show is cut in a very
unique fashion
like it's not just a typical live stream
it's like these little cuts and the
graphics and then you do it like it's
really the production value you know
what i'm saying
it's very unique so again i gotta shout
you out too i'm glad
kik brought that to my attention because
again
the statue community gaming comics all
of this
is what the laws come from you know i'm
saying like this is all
they're so compatible they're so similar
you know what i'm saying so again salute
to what you're doing man
that is really cool and again it's the
friday open night
you know what i'm saying podcast you
know i said i like that and then
of course seeing the unboxings of the
new statues and getting people
information they may need on potential
purchases that they think it up so
that's pretty cool too
well i got to tell you i think over the
over the time i've been doing this i
think i
i didn't age a lot because i'm telling
you i lived unboxed this dude
i had like sit uh sit in some epsom salt
after that
it used to be it is hard but you know
but um i i got a shout out y'all too man
i mean i really
appreciate what you guys are doing man i
mean you got to
writers and editing lords of gaming.net
and i was like
you guys are amazing you know and i
enjoy watching every sunday
and everything so um hey shout out to my
hat to you guys too man you know so
absolute brother
ain't recognizing this game you don't
recognize game brother yo salute people
don't realize how hard it is to build
something from total scratch
yes yes and like no no
no cheat sheets because a lot of people
get cheesed
organic but when you build something
from total scratch
you don't know anything so but you know
what it is attic the love is
different you know what i'm saying like
look at the chat you know what i'm
saying they're saying we got i don't get
300
we know when it was five it was two you
know what i'm saying and it was like yo
why you wouldn't jump on and you were
supposed to watch the show
you don't say it like from that so it's
like at the end of the day it's just so
cool
you count your blessings you know what
i'm saying like you you respect it
especially when it's organic and the
thing that you know thor said that
really resonate with me
is that and the lord's we've experienced
that this is not like bragging or trying
to be egotistical but
you start to see your influence on
others and you know we never throw it in
no one's face
but we know where that comes from right
so we know when we hear
bushes and you know say this and other
stuff or other
we know and we don't we don't take it
like an ego or cocky anything like that
we know we're doing something right
because people will appreciate us
right yeah and i'm a culture slang you
know you you take it
because what i would rather you do is
say throw it in the bushes then curse at
somebody
facts you know i would rather you take
that vernacular and use that vernacular
to to to further something on and it's
funny as hell
so you know we use that instead of
cursing at somebody and the dude would
be like throw me in the bushes you're
going
wow and
you know it starts to resonate then it
starts to hype and go over faces
so and it's a good thing because we're
all about we we're not about separation
facts it's all about inclusion inclusion
we're all gamers you're all statue
collectors we all watch them comics we
go to the movies
when i got him i got i knew i knew i had
it
it has to be it has to be his favorite
character the first one
i said and it and it has to be from
sideshow
all right because i've been he didn't
know because all right so
when i when i do my kos right well
before
he would go and get this uh the
breakdowns of the
you know he does the website stuff right
so i will send him to sideshow
now when you send somebody to a candy
store
and they just go on the side just to
look around and get measurements they're
looking at the candy like man i look
good
if it's not his stuff he don't care
right i know him
so when that when daniel bell came out
with that silver surface oh
and that and that frankie ray oh frankie
ray sailed the dale on it
right and she got a light up i say i got
it
there's no excuse wait you're not giving
yourself enough credit because
i was like i was telling throw off off
here like
i'm very particular with surfer
i'm very like you you know the era and
no disrespect to the great artist
before but i'm that ron lim penciller
the specific pencil is that i'm like it
showcases his power cosmic correct and i
like the form factor
so i see surface of the front like i
don't care about that
but what is your flavor
yeah that's what i'm saying i don't have
time for one of these things
like but it's like it's like i won't get
into multiple types of like mmos i only
got time for one
but it's like when it's your man's done
right yeah it's nothing yeah it's
different it hit different
i was like all right you got it you got
it and i tell you finding out in this
game
everybody got a poison yes if you you
can say no all you want to
but when they come out with that one
i got something special for him when his
character
you get that see thor knows too don't
know exactly what i got for you mm-hmm
so and that's going to stop the little
tidal wave
oh look i'm gonna set you lucky because
somebody's custom surfers
yeah crazy i'm staying with see this is
y'all bad down shave the devil
anyway move it over here
we gotta finish off nice we have
gerald mack with the five hours which
atari 5200 was the first console that
put coin off games in the living room
that's how
i go back hashtag i'm 50.
we have the living flame with the two
dollars super chat morning lords game
awards in the bush
nominations then we have lucius augustus
the two dollar super chat vanguard is
the best way to play mass effect
2 then we have perfect shogun with the 5
super chat jumping back in the raid with
my clan i'll catch the vod
chat that like button good to see you
man that's what's up mm-hmm
we got pixel bit g with the five dollar
super chat y'all keep doing the lord's
work and making best podcasts every week
thank you
but that's my brooklyn bias
brooklyn what's up stand up then we got
stitches for five dollar super chat i
was here when there was only six people
in the chat hello
i didn't recommend game but attic had no
game yesterday
yeah he was going into attic in the rain
he's good
tremendous history tremendous what
you're doing in the statute community
so we know what time it is you know what
time it is
you know what you hear for the people
they meet
those top five video games
or franchises of all time
uh let's go uh franchise would be hard
games i'll say games um
okay that's fine mass effect is in there
i can't put them in that order you know
mass effect 2 definitely
is on the list definitely on the list
you know what i mean
um that game was just and it was
different every time
that's the thing about it it's different
every time and then
you know you discover different stuff
like you you go way out there and find
something like wow i know this was here
you know what i mean
yeah it was different experience every
time that's definitely in my top five
um gears obviously you know that's
that's just
that i can just that's like a period in
my life i could just say five
um street fighter 2 no doubt first
street fighter reference
i was like talking about it was just
i mean it was literally again the old
west like i i remember being in
in the lunchroom this dude came to slam
his stuff down need to see you today man
it was funny because that was the first
dude i thought that he had he used
blanca and i was
and he got he came back talk man stuff
of course i went to the dojo
yeah i think i had to go to the doctor
and i'll do the class i just said
that's nice whoop you again man you know
that street fighter it did it because it
it created friendships because i that's
how i'm
king not street fighter 2 but it was the
alpha because i had it i was the way
this at school and i hadn't met
king yet so when i came back i i went to
hang out with cog
and i like and king was there he
immediately he's
talking smacks now i'm looking at smart
i'm like [ __ ] who is this old man that's
hanging out
you're giving us you know so i'm like
who is this old man that cocktail
immediately starts talking smack about
street but i'm like oh hell no
and literally we were there for like
hours
going back and forth and yeah pretty
much finished
a tie basically both of us that's how
that's how we both were in the street
fighter outfit
and after that it was love after that it
was just family after that
but it was one of those things that it
street fighter
you know even even the tough competition
like you
went at each other hard it just created
these friendships that like as long as
you wasn't cheating
yeah if you weren't turtling or doing
anything like that yet actually
no no no so we got the street fighter
that is classic indeed so we got mass
effect we got kids
we got street fighter 2 so obviously
it got to be a star wars game in this
course
the first oh yes that game and i'ma tell
you something that game
it was one part it was the first time in
my life that i hated darth vader
you fought him at the end at the second
time
yeah it was like you couldn't do nothing
to him i was like
you know what's crazy like you try to
jump he's
held you know what the crazy thing is
they're lucky
that um they put that game as not canon
because
the star destroyer is the strongest shot
i've ever lived
he didn't just like beat individually he
beat them both
you get so powerful with that character
it's ridiculous yeah
he literally took a start what was the
the exact model that like he
grabbed it out of the air and oh the
star destroyer yeah yeah
and it's like and i had to tell right
now he's like
yeah we actually have a small one either
we're talking about the ones
that that whole armies wow yo that was
probably
until i got to this last star wars game
the force unleashed one and two was
probably
my best star wars game this game
the latest one just really did
everything
well like very buttoned down realistic
that's what i liked what they did yeah
because there were certain stuff that
you know as strong as that
individual was there's a reason that
made him knock canon cause
yeah yeah this new person like
you you it's it's a you know once people
pop in they eat supposed to be
guess what they don't beat them so you
know
oh yeah that salute it doesn't get
enough credit i'd love it so we do we
get the five we got again uh
that's four no no that's four one one
more so one it got to be it's a god of
war
that's that's that's unique
that game was special playstation
playstation
this one i kept seeing i was like i have
to play this game
yeah and it was like you know the the
the voice acting it's it got times where
they grabbed you you know i mean you act
you know uh chris judge nailed it even i
don't know the little boy's name
and um the dude to play it was it was
crazy
i mean it was just they they need to
make a movie out of that game i think
i think i will say that i think one of
the reasons you think that is because
you haven't played the other ones
because like with the other ones like
they had all of that
and they had everything else like
because i do feel like because of the
direction they went with god of war
they sacrificed a lot of things that
made god of war god of war
yeah now i did go back and watch some of
them on youtube cause like it was some
because like stuff had happened and i
was like well what what are they talking
about
i went back and watched it and i
i didn't like because it was the guy
from living single that did his voice
wasn't it
you know i forgot his name uh yeah
really and i just didn't enjoy he did
like too much yelling for me
okay and like i didn't enjoy kratos as
much
with him as i did you know what's funny
i know you're in the same pocket
the hardcore god of war fans i respect
because you guys
you know you guys follow me right now
the first ones is
to me the greatest the great i know and
i remember that i'm respecting
anybody's opinion on the last one
because
this is a kratos that is tired yes he
doesn't
he doesn't really want to do none of
this stuff that he's got to do
but he has to do it for this boy that
you know his mother that he loved and
you know it's the whole story the story
is a great story going through
i always say this is not my god award no
i don't know
what okay what a lot of people don't
understand
is it's like what made kratos do the
stuff kratos did it was
it was the loss of his love like that's
what he didn't drive
but he reclaimed that he got that back
you know my
original person but he had that sense of
happiness back
so he calmed the hell down no and i get
it
so for me i remember the game in the
boom basticness and the over the top
and the action it was like fighting the
boss everything was cool about it i
remember having the vita version and i
was enjoying it
but again it was just to me more run of
the mill and it was it was cool but i
wasn't like enthralled
but when he got into this mold for
whatever reason i'm kind of like where
thor is at like
it captured me and then graphically i
just love the way it looks
you're just graphical horse
those first three got matured
he's ripping the wings off for icarus in
the sky
and putting them on his back
[Music]
in 2018 if they had given you the
bombastic fights like in the originals i
think you would have been fine
i think that that's and it's like i said
i don't have a problem with god of war i
just felt like the direction they went
because of the direction the artwork and
how they
you know did the last of us effect
that's what i like to call them yes
it made it so costly they couldn't do
certain things that was that was the
norm for god always
it completely changed set pieces yeah
it's ridiculous no i get it
i get it anyone who's uh again i'm fraud
and i admit like
the first dude that wasn't for me but
this was for me like
i love his maturity where he's at at
this stage he's grounded for
his ground and then he got the ground i
like the the atreus relationship you
know what i'm saying like i i just it
was the stepson
yeah like i just liked it and then it
was it was over the top and i was like
okay
i'd say even for the combat like if you
look at how ariel right cradles used to
be in one two three right
all cradles is he's he's super grounded
he's not jumping in here right here dude
i don't have a jump button right the
power he displays on the ground no
it's very like i'm not i'm not jumping
i'm just going to pound you into the
ground type of power
and it feels right for that like to me
the progression in terms of where he is
in his life
in every aspect the story everything and
even the way he fights
feels right for the story they're trying
to tell him
it would feel weird in the if in
ragnarok all of a sudden he's jumping
around and doing it would feel wrong
he's not yeah he's not young like that
because
he was he was young
i do want the big bombastic battles
though i want them
well hopefully this playstation 5 can do
that i think
i think what i don't think it's mainly
about like a thing of power i think it's
like development time like
they say they spent so much time making
even the stranger fight like
like i love god of war it's getting my
game of the generation
i mean i don't know ghosts might be
above that but it's like at the end of
the day
it's like i don't think that they
surpassed in terms of
combat that that that's what god of war
three god of war two god of war
is the epic battle and i don't if they
ever surpassed
this hour of the game exactly you can't
surpass the first
the first three games when your main
mental battle
is the same damn troll in a different
color
yeah i was about to say that they did
reuse a lot of assets like yo
here come another troll i said before
and i'll say it again i
there's i've never been more
disappointed when they were hyping up
this
this this gateway underkeeper like
protect the the world the the realm of
the underworld whatever they call it
in north mythology and you get to him
and he's a purple dancer
[Laughter]
anyway yeah shout out to purple trolls
amazing franchise an amazing top five so
i gotta ask you a final question
as far as favorite console of
all time and then we could throw you a
bonus favorite statue
four times oh okay or just
okay no the statue could be any and then
the console got to be any generation
just one if you could only have one 360.
okay so we got the 360. we got this it
was just so many milestones for me on
360. i feel you
and if you know i could i could play i
could go back through the
campaign on gears one right now and
still
you know and because i remember playing
on the uh
you know the multiplayer and it used to
be this little kid we used to play with
his name was cue ball i'll never forget
this child until like
dirt he used to whoop on us and he and
he
on that he like don't you run from me
boy
man i am not taking this no more so i
went back and he's a
shotgun this is when i started using the
shotgun yeah oh i said man i'ma play on
hard i'ma just use the shotgun i'm not
using the landsat i'm gonna learn how to
use this thing
uh-huh and i made it and i got good i'm
gonna go find it
hey i took him down i said i have
arrived
you know absolutely i think that's the
reason i can't mess with gears to that
degree is like
i played halo where you know pr stuff
was extremely
you know dominant in halo but you
actually had you know accessible
on all things that you didn't spawn with
a shotgun in halo what
i like how he went to go find him that's
the fault
i found my joint was meant to show time
yeah nba live remember
show time listen i don't know where you
are to this day
but that was my dude on xbox um
next band x-man bro right
and for all yeah yo he he's to beat the
hell out of the kid it's funny you said
that because those are the days when the
online community
started and when you faced you know your
face those those the certain
appointments they were so good
that when you saw that gamertag come up
in the matchmaking yeah and you like oh
you it for a long
night have you ever have you ever had
those like
friends that when they come over you was
like man i gotta deal with this
yes it's like you're debating on going
home it's like do i really want to do it
you don't want to deal with this right
now
by myself
so we need that statue now that's what's
that statue now i would say
the the best one that i've seen in
person yeah easy as the the xm
hulkbuster
i mean that game that that statue is
like
awe-inspiring when you see it and the
thing about it is you can
it comes with it's actually two
quarter-scale statues you got
hulkbuster and they got like an iron man
quarter scale you can put inside of them
you can put them on the side and it's
details it lights up
and it's it's just it's crazy amazing
i'm a huge fan of anime and i remember
uh king sent me a goku sketch instead oh
yeah
go that's how we're going to get him and
i would i was like
i didn't even i didn't even open it i
was like no
you're going to see it because you got a
heat to see okay so now attic does my
kos
so he he doesn't know that saying goku
that i sent him is the one i got
pre-ordered that uh
so when i do goku and i'm gonna do that
story
on on on that that google screen you
realize i'm gonna be in that comment
section if you don't get something right
right
first first all my stories are for me
just like attic world is for you
all my stories is for me that doesn't
make it completely accurate for somebody
else
i'm just going to tell you a snapshot of
why i care about this statue
i'm going to give you a snapshot on why
i care about this character and why i
got it
but it it's literally just my experience
because somebody else can have a totally
different experience with the same book
and the same character but with me it's
just going to be that little thing
but i got you though what you're saying
that the war and the king were about to
collide in the
in this comments yes pretty much so look
that yo
tremendous tremendous video game sister
the tremendous statue community
lord thor blessing us from darth castle
x where can the five people find you and
what do you have going on sir
well you can find us on dcx channel we
on every friday night when the lights
are bright
you know dcx over mike and um we
actually got i think wednesday we have a
live unboxing coming where
uh a man archangel getting his batman
who laughs from prime one studios
absolutely
so that's coming in and that's that's
probably going down and then uh
show black friday will be on so um
that's pretty much it for this week
you guys want to come through i'm
talking about the stuff so
you know we got a plug okay so so let's
go
being that uh uh the the host with the
most
uh is forgetting we got we got raffles
coming
listen guys you see these statues that's
behind me and you know a lot of them is
uh
twelve hundred dollars sixteen hundred
dollars and stuff like that the same
thing
with statues that are behind him so um
we're in a partnership with a
with a company and we will be doing
raffles now these raffles is you know
anywhere from twenty to fifty dollars
you know per entry
um you're gonna have to join the darth
castle x uh family
on facebook to be in it uh we're gonna
do randomized
and you can get a chance to win one of
these statues that's what's up
all right so all you got to do is just
uh pay for your raffle
and you know uh the statue will be
shipped out to you you win
we also you're having different
giveaways uh weekly
and also if you see any statue that
you're interested in
xm studio statues which is the creme de
la creme
we sell these statues at a premium um
these statues will definitely get
shipped out to you uh we can beat uh
tons of people damn facebook i'm out
come on
pc what it is is the statue community is
huge
on facebook and once if
you if you said facebook i can't get
with facebook
then that means that you don't deserve a
1200 statue
if you feel that uh facebook is a
barrier facebook will not be a barrier
to me i ought to be downloading that app
right now putting my face on right now
and doing it
right now oh absolutely you know to get
to uh
where you want to get to but trust me
like thor said
it is nothing compared to when you have
this statue in hand
now the only caveat is what we ask is
this you win
you do the live boxing unboxing on dolph
castlex that's what's up when the statue
gets to you
we coordinate the day that fits in your
schedule and we do the live unboxing
right there
just to show the world and everyone that
you got the statue for 20 bucks
it's amazing facts and you know and
you're doing a live unboxing and you're
part of the family
so you know he he he just glossed over
that part but that's exactly where we at
tremendous great to have you in the
realm man again dcx is the youtube
channel please support this brother
friday night and again was it 9 30 or 9
p.m eastern 9 p.m eastern like i said
here exactly king is on now i like the
the unique stuff the way he does
yes the way he does the cuts of the
brother a pleasure to have you man we
going rock off but you know y'all back
in the round we already know
i appreciate you guys and i love what
you guys are doing man i'm big fan of
you i watch every sunday at least for a
while you know
when i can i gotta deal with my dog job
in the mud
so um yeah you guys keep doing what
you're doing man and uh anytime you all
will come hang out on
on friday night bright lights
dc actually already know what it is so
we got some show you copter you copted
already oh no
they got me this this is how the statue
thing works uh
you can do um pay all at one time or you
can do
the little by little yeah you did pay as
you go yeah every month
at you lightweight yeah but yeah yeah
and you know and also they also have
their own credit card and their own
system and stuff like that
you know for uh if you want to build
credit and stuff and you get points
yeah so he's gonna get at least uh uh
some points off of the next statue that
you know might pop up for him
you know so i just sit there and i just
i just watch the beautiful nature of
everything happening
that's what it all is it's like a pusher
that's all they say thank you
thank you he's like dang you're fishing
[Laughter]
i want to stay married i'm not going
down yeah you better stay stay the
halloween stay there i don't i don't
think there's a character
for you though like no you have to be
though it will have to
be a wrestling character or it will have
to be one of those tekken characters
they do got those tekken characters you
know batman has said it would be bad
batman for him for real yeah it is see
there it is
moving on we got the paul we got to get
into the show
the people spoken to the question with
the official launch of both next-gen
consoles
which next-gen feature has you impressed
the most the winner of the three-way ilp
poll at 66 percent of the vote
was series x quick resume
coming in at second lower 17 percent of
the vote
was the messy lords i don't care
playstation 5
and xbox play 65 crashes and xbox series
x catches on fire girl
and last place at 16 of the vote was the
playstation dual five playstation five
duel sets controller shout out to the
lords who participated lost off you
missed
what was your what do you agree with the
the realm what do you feel
well actually a quick resume has been in
the bushes for me man yeah i didn't work
from either i was gonna say shut it down
or something i know there was some
issues i think that's one of the reasons
that
like i had to reset my uh my console
because i think the quick resume
works but it's not shutting down like
in the background like it's supposed to
and it's caught and it's being cause
if you if you want you're in the game
and you use quicker zoom
you can't go back to that other game and
quit like
you bring it back up so i think what's
happening
is the game is reading two games going
on at the simultaneously
so when i download something it's
halfing the speed
yeah yeah i don't know if the half in
the speed thing is like i said that
handshake it's not recognizing that the
handshake is over
and then so it's continuing throttle
down
still working out the kings on certain
things and uh yeah i think from what i
was told
some they will be disabling until they
fix for some games until they fix it
with issues
but we got to move on so solve your up
but um
i think you want to set it up like a
two-part thing right so one like briefly
your experience or whatever and then
the second part i think i was going to
tackle as far as the whole
multi-pla aspect right but okay i mean
i'm just being selfish because i missed
last week yeah i said some of this i
said something okay so you said in the
beginning yeah you said most of it all
right
yeah i mean that's it i mean pretty much
just to go a little more in depth what i
played on xbox i obviously been playing
valhalla
um i gotta have to echo what despite
what we're gonna talk about in a few
minutes about
multi-flats um kid last week was talking
about dirt
dirt looks freaking fantastic though i
forget about
i don't have i don't have a tv that's
doing on 120 yet i haven't upgraded
so that that part i have not seen for
myself
what running at 4k 60 yes that game
looks beautiful it looks beautiful
and i played the falconer as well what i
didn't get which
i should is yakuza because they think
about yakuza oh you got to get that
yeah the thing is there's so many big
games like if you look at assassin's
creed and then watch it
you'll be solved this debo in the
situation when it comes to
huge games so then you have this other
humongous rpg
and the thing about it is like if we
want to see more of these type of games
on xbox we have to support now because
it's not in game pass
because i want i want the sales to be
there because i want more of this same
thing i literally said you see this
that's when you miss a week i literally
said everything you said
it's the thing like if you talk about oh
there's nothing exclusively on xbox why
don't they get japanese
and they get an exclusive like what's up
get out there you got it you're not a
rapper you can't read
that and not rep it right for you phil
did that for you
that's what i've been playing and again
on playstation the only three that i got
um is demon souls miles morales and uh
and what's him call it uh obviously the
built-in game
astros playroom right um i'm gonna tell
you right now like demon souls is fanta
the the layer of gloss they put on that
game
is kind of insane insane the guts of the
game are the same that's the same game
but the layer of gloss and and sort of
the quality of life improvements to just
how it plays and looks and moves
is is really significant it's something
else to see
i got to tell you man miles i it kind of
brought a tear to my eye bro
just the new york vibe
[Applause]
of a young afro-latino like kind of and
they're being prominently over the gas
so tell me you didn't get kind of pissed
off when
uh she was calling her mijo and stuff
like that
when he was mixing every spanish
into one ball like a puerto rican from
puerto rico
we'll sing people we'll say that all
right now a new eureka not necessarily
that
much but i did appreciate that her
the way she spoke she definitely felt
like a new eureka like
that was it didn't sound like a
dominican person she didn't sound like
she sounded like a puerto rican person
delegation has approved i appreciated
that
absolutely i appreciated the the
whatchamacallit the christmas season
celebration
the music i appreciated seeing pastels
i was like oh my god they did it yo and
the the greatest thing was
for my wife to look at that and she's
like
what game is this i'm like it's
spider-man she's like spider-man's not
black i'm like
this is another spider-man and when i
explained it to her i was like he's he's
he's african-american and puerto rican
and she's like oh
because she saw the puerto rican flags
in it wait did you download some dlc to
have this all in the game and i'm like
no you did game like this
you did download the new dlc
oh my gosh to see her
see that and like just look at like the
street fair and the people dancing
inside us on the street
and some people dancing in the world
some people dancing in portugal like
that one girl was broken but the other
girl was
oh
yo everything about that game just put a
smile on my
face the way they rap and why i see the
way the
i knew it was on not to cut you but i
knew it was one
as soon as the title screen hit and he
was on that four train or whatever he
was on
and the tim's on and the shirley and he
got off
i was like and they used the real the
and that and that that i've never been
in quality mode
oh crazy oh brother like i haven't even
touched the performance mode i know that
looks ridiculous
but that ray trace you're up on a
building and you're just
you see the reflection
[Music]
they trimmed all of the fat from from
spider-man in a way makes this such a
tight experience
bro i i'm so happy with that game very
happy with that game
so let's get to the smoke
you see the chat ready so um look you
know obviously shout out to
digital foundry our gentleman lord uh
richard ledbetter and of course
john lennon we've had on the show many
times and um yeah
so it looks like the early initial
face-offs have happened
again most recently as far as from the
playstation 5 and the xbox series x
most recently assassin's creed valhalla
and dirt 5
and many people's surprise of the
playstation 5 is reigning supreme
in these comparisons so let's get every
one of them yeah
i get we get cod today actually oh okay
will you call today oh
i didn't know that okay so let's get the
elephant out the room first which is
the series s obviously you know what i'm
saying um i believe they they talked
about with
um valhalla not hitting 60.
so that was i believe that's 30 there
and then i think again with dirt
the 120 mode and all that other stuff
you know what i'm saying that was there
but
the thing that caught me so i surprised
at least a lot of people
was that the playstation 5 as far as
valhalla star valhalla first much closer
to 60 frames
target most of the time while the series
x could struggle it says in fact
they're noticing uh play65 is delivering
up to a 25
performance advantage over its microsoft
equivalent in
identical scenarios and then the last
thing um that they mentioned was as more
games target 60 frames in the cross gen
period
and don't quite sustain the target we're
seeing the resurgence of screen
tearing so that's a big thing and then
they were talking about
why our variable refresh rate is
important and again shout out to the lg
the god led oled lords you know i mean
if you got that feature on
you're able to mitigate a lot of stuff
but a lot of people who don't have it
if you know they're really experiencing
it so they had that and then they also
talked about dirt
and what particularly hit me was the 120
hertz bone saw
which is you know both of them doing it
but the playstation 5 almost looks like
a
really more high quality graphic
fidelity in that mode
you know i'm saying as opposed to that
sort of fidelity assets yes
yes like fox virgin is barren right yeah
oh the results are out so i got to bring
it to the realm it's very spicy
right now crazy it's crazy in the
twitter street so um
yeah with all this stuff coming out um
soft like how concerned
are we the world's most powerful castle
is being beaten head-to-head in
multi-flats look
long-term like listen long-term i'm not
concerned right shout out to coke for a
video about you know how the fact that
you know sdks are behind and they're
it's particularly on the xbox um but at
the same time it's just
my this is my feeling just a gut feeling
right
why why this
why does it always have to be a butt
when it comes to xbox and it
it makes me mad that it just it's always
a butt
and it's like the console that we heard
the most
form of waiting yeah it's always it's
always a waiting it's always a butt
and i'm like and it's like i said it
long term yeah
long time not really worried about it
we'll see patches this stuff will get
fixed and improved upon
but it's one of those things like why
does it happen
and you know how important as stupid it
is as it is
you know how important narrative is at
the start of the generation
especially when they they can throw the
narrative at you that you don't have
have big exclusives in comparison to
what playstation has
when all those narratives are in tow
again it's like damn it like
you know you you why does this continue
to happen to them
let me let me let me cut you for a
second i just want to ask you this um
now
you didn't mention the whole thing as
far as it was at the sdks whatever
number in it so like what do you say to
those who say okay
right you're right solve but you know
the fact that
the developers from my understanding
they didn't get they didn't even have
the kits until like june or whatever
because
basically they were trying to say is
like oh well if they wanted the full
rdna tool then they had to wait today
like what do you say to that or
you like still what i say to that is
this you have to there has to be some
some some communication in terms of how
you're marketing the machine
right and in terms of what you're going
to get day one out of the box because
you it makes you sound foolish when your
whole spiel marketing is the most
powerful console ever
and and then when it when it drops even
even though there are circumstances as
to why these performance differences are
happening
the fact of the matter is that the pro
the pudding tastes like doodoo right now
oh damn it and it's just like the
comparisons and this is so
extra i'm kicking i can't charging up
keep charging up in the back
when he does his analogies charging up
you don't see anything
only people that are gonna have this
conversation with people with them tvs
they can do that
the playstation your playstation dev
kits was made
back in january back in january with
your big box your big goofy
box was back in january they should have
worried about that user interface to
stop crashing
well that's
the user interface affects everyone okay
it affects everyone
everyone well now what what software is
talking about
is affecting the one percent
[Music]
you know why this doesn't affect me let
me tell you why it doesn't affect me
because i'm not buying none of those
games on playstation
but it literally does not affect me i'm
not buying anything over there
you only got one game and that game is
on playstation 4.
so so wearing another uh king where it
doesn't affect you guys
you know what doesn't affect you too all
that stuff that he said
because you're not doing 120 hertz
so it don't hurt you so yeah
just sitting there capping like yo you
know what i'm saying the playstation is
doing 120 hertz
better than the xbox i won't say that
for sure
who don't have that tv
listen they don't have the tv they don't
have the capabilities
and they don't probably even have a play
station
you cannot rely on the cheat tv and be
like that's that's how you fix it
so this is what i'm gonna say this let's
go i'm gonna say this part right here
there's a ton of capping dudes dudes are
scared to death right
i want y'all to know xbox is brute
frosting it
they don't have no they they dev kits
wasn't there so you said because they
natural
off rip and they already ready there's
about to be a wrap with it
listen with no death kids off the rip
they like this
with the no shirt with the abs just
natural they sitting there flexing their
ass
anyway so these dudes at these
playstations is like but i'm saying
though my abs is a little bit more
ripped under here because yeah
under here is a little bit better so he
been hitting it hard he been going every
day and you say because
xbox is all natural they even hit the
gym yet they should be ashamed
that they even close
it has been marketing the most powerful
and that's what a playstation does
without a dev kit like that
and but this is this is we look at the
playstation 4.
exactly exactly you know what there's
none of the developers
of the place to go listen i don't own a
dev kit
i don't own spk or ddk and
neither did any of the developers
so when they say yo push they join
through the pc
and xbox said don't worry i got that why
you gotta keep doing it
i do that i do that yo you gotta stop
doing that
so what happens now when they got the
dev kits and they're using our dna too
and they're busting them out
do you mean i see this for like almost a
year maybe oh no that's that's a lot
listen listen dudes ain't seen it for
four years
[Music]
i'm not acknowledging
i just got one quick question for you
king one real quick question
how'd you get a playstation is delayed
brother he said he's off lunch it's a
soft launch a lot of dudes don't got him
a lot of news is getting cat food right
now
we're getting a box full of cat food
that's the witches just
we're clear we're clear here okay you're
saying that the playstation nation
should be ashamed of themselves because
that the the series acts off of the
natural
off how we go off the rip no working out
and
they they no death kick and they just
they they still side by side
so that they should be ashamed okay you
know what it is
imagine this right imagine you been
working out
all year long you in the gym you know
maxed out your bench you don't did
everything and then i show up i haven't
worked out for two years
i just come in the gym and me and you
doing the same thing
we're doing the same thing but all i'm
doing is like one rep behind you yeah
i'm doing this you're gonna look over at
me and like what's up with this dude
like cause it's all now
you can't be doing that so when when we
start to work out
and we start to take that pre-workout
and we get on the same stuff that the
playstation's on
where are you at all right i feel you
but it solves the
addicts all right but it's solved in
addict's defense king there's no defense
the narrative that your dude has been
doing is that he's the biggest he's the
strongest
no one's the people he's been telling
you
that when he come through he's the
biggest dude in the gym
so if you come to the gym and the dude
is out lifting him ain't
going to look a little sick if he was a
ufc fighter right and he'd come in and
be like i'm the biggest and the baddest
but the first year of his contract he
loses three fights
the other thing you're saying is because
of the fact that
if you have a lg or you have a tv with
vrr
that it doesn't have these issues on
this series that's because so basically
you say dudes are capping
about these about these problems and
they don't get their tv
like this pc there
you know what it is these dudes don't
this ain't last generation
this ain't playstation 4 versus xbox one
uh you know the off divert this this you
ain't coming here with your tcl my guys
it's over step your game up
if i catch anybody in my inbox talking
about
variable refresh rate you better show me
the serial number
on your tv because i am sick and tired
news out here front
like you know the playstation out here
moving way stronger
100 120 you didn't see anything
so he brought it
right now they just doing eye hustle
to give a hand to this man king for the
for the great dancing he's doing right
now
oh ryan man you are giving dance move
ryan's a run for his money man
i don't even know what thing right now
in a box there's nobody
so all right all i see is the xbox doing
this
so it's that fun and just for the record
so that off the off natty xbox or daddy
team
and the fact that dudes is frauding
because they don't have the team
we have the tv okay i just want to
understand your logic here i'm just
trying to
they don't even have the 1500 accessory
that's needed
exactly they still
finance with the five dollars to attack
gears 5 runs beautiful 4k 60 at ultimate
settings but multiply
multiple devs can fit can't figure out
the series x
they need time to figure the system i
guess then we have element appeal with
the 5
super chat sulfur can be fixed in patch
hardware looking at your problem sony
tony bryant with the 5 super chat xbox
basically playing pc ports right now
that's why back compat is clear
advantage
cyberpunk gonna flip this narrative
since it will be back compact
no we got pixel bit g with the five
dollar super chat the series x sdk is a
soft launch
but he but he had one point dudes
capping on cheap tvs but right now
series l
got balloon check
yes i believe no we have the living
flame two dollars super chat guys relax
ps5's are breaking anywhere it's hashtag
yo cause once they start pushing past
they juggle in too much the balls start
dropping
going crazy so who said here we go here
we go
i said here we go he found something
he's about to go in
they already know they already know if
you push that playstation too hard it
will crack
so what's happening is they was trying
to impress digital founders and they
start breaking all over the place
yo digital yo guess what we could do we
can do 120 hertz
this is better here this is busy
let me give up this is going crazy love
out here popping muscles lifting weights
and popping muscles
this box is more than capable of it but
like like i started off my diatribe
yes why why do we have to deal with this
why is this the thing it's always xbox
yeah let me jump back
this is a funny topic um yeah i want to
shout out two people i wanna shout out
um shout out to dealer and all shout out
to
mikey bar i surprised i wanted to uh get
their commentary in
so yeah deal actually made a comment and
he was just basically saying how like
again i didn't even realize this the
xbox g series gdk
was only certified in june 2020 some
developers went without series x and s
kits
and he said that's only one aspect of
the story so the fact that
a lot of these games again i'm not
making excuses i'm just telling you what
what they say as far as far as
what you call it the uh gdk so they're
saying that a lot of them didn't even
have the kids and now the thing that was
interesting was mikey barra's comments
because they people a lot of people
wanted to mike they say hey you know
what's your opinion about this issue you
know i'm saying
texas dirt 5 valhalla you know why does
the series x you know not perform well
some
as far as the quality of these games in
these um comparison
so mike said not sure someone fell
asleep
during their job making sure third party
was ready he said
probably be fixed in a game update soon
but unfortunately to solve point to have
to deal with that narrative
right now he said the system is clearly
more powerful
he actually said i was surprised and
should have better looking games versus
any other console at the moment so these
are mike's comment look this is what i
think about why everybody asking my
question
because like this why are you asking the
former employee the question
but this is what i don't learn
everything that you said he didn't
confirm what you said
in confirming anything i said because i
don't work there either so
so it's nothing my mind is conjectural
like mine is from the window looking in
like
you know like like just like his mine is
from the window
looking in and and dudes keep asking yo
mike what do you think stop asking my
questions
why don't you ask me why don't you ask
the developer that's actually working on
the kids
your former friend about you i'm not
gonna ask your reference
about a former friend for which you so
there's no way in hell i'm looking at
his comments like
what if he had if he has not gonna
happen at least curb stomped them right
then you'd be like all right i don't us
what you're saying he was very objective
very objective no all right moving on
moving on past mike
his comments before and after has always
been a little
so me personally this is what i'm saying
i'm saying
me personally i don't care what anybody
else is this is you me and him sitting
on the outside looking in the window
okay
cause you you're like here the same boat
as you i get where you going so why
don't you ask
me these questions because we doing the
same thing
anyway even though he does have insight
because he did twitter but i know what
you're going i know where you're going
you know where you're going i know yeah
even though he worked there for god
knows how and we're part of the project
that designer but we
go we know you listen at the end of the
day is this you know
i feel what you say and and my thing is
i do feel what's all the same because at
the end of the day
listen nobody want to hear it the
consumer don't want to hear it right
when you look at it consumer can't see
it
but the the informed consumer what
doesn't want to hear
any excuses that's just the bottom line
they don't want it like yo you said you
was the most powerful
why are you not so now the problem is
this perceived strength that was
supposed to be there right
most people assume would be there gets
taken away and i think it's exacerbated
by the fact
that the first party was there as well
at launch so now you have this
this double problem now the thing about
it is
this though that's how i look at it when
the kids were not there
right and they showing things again i'm
not saying this is definitely the reason
but when they have the performance of a
halo infinite
and we go like dogs like how did that
get out the door you know what i'm
saying like
you know and then if these are being
done
without the kit right and like you said
off the rip all i was saying is it does
give me hope that maybe even a title
like infinite
can improve what i'm saying once they
have it but the thing is i just think i
agree with soft though
because of the stakes were so high and
it's always like okay wait until this or
wait until that
right that's what exacerbates the issue
i think they will
get the kiss and stuff we'll improve on
them and we'll see it but it's up to
them you know what i'm saying it's up to
them to get them out
ever especially with xbox
yes uh hurry up and wait though yo yo
next year though it's gonna be hot but
this is this is where i say this is
where this is different guys
this is where this is different and i
can say this with all confidence
in my heart none of these dudes got the
television
so when i say this that they don't see
what they thought they saw anyway
and half these dudes don't got a
playstation because they can't get them
because there's a soft launch see you in
february
um and dudes that do got a playstation
half of them are bricked out anyway
so you're gonna say half those dudes
can't see anything the other
half could see it and then you say that
half that can see
they probably got an x maybe they might
have an
s and they're sitting there figuring out
they're not buying the same exact games
that's a very select few people right so
you're not going to go by valhalla
valhalla just to so you can do your own
digital foundry
if you are then you are a sad person you
can knock yourself out with all that
yeah i didn't even buy half of these
games
at all because i'm waiting for black
friday
all right so i'm waiting for the deals
to show up when the deals show up then
i'm gonna buy these games and i can talk
to you about them
but again if your tv doesn't take
advantage of this situation
stay out of the conversation vg said
half a brick come on
how about less than one percent of brick
he said you go there that's a lie
too many people did we're not gonna say
less than one percent listen
if a hundred thousand got released and
over
fifty thousand of them were broke
so go to the king they do it too much to
get to these performance goals in a
playstation
it's breaking because of this it's a
variable system
oh god here we go here we go no we found
out that it juggles
it's either or so either you're going to
get the graphics or you're going to get
the speed
so when they try to do both the system
shut down set it up
shut it down you're not getting both oh
so like either or it's either
graphics or speed you ain't never hear
nobody tell about oh my xbox shut up
i ain't seen none no but i see and i was
sitting there my listen
i'm telling you from me uh this was you
my playstation you know what
matter of fact let's put our hands
together all right let's check this out
how many people on this panel
have played a playstation in the shut
off or they did something weird to them
minds have mine minecraft mine has it
mm-hmm
what about yours okay so so
it's so it's totally one you're gonna
want to count mine too
and that means that he didn't even get a
chance to probably blaze yet because you
know your man taking a week off
so we're gonna act sovereign at the end
of the week
this king this is ant sedona king this
is very antidote
by the people the people i know all the
people i know has hit me with that error
like yo yo
what's up with this i'm like oh man bro
it's all right just reset it and hold it
down
and then maybe if you blow on the back
of it it might come back a lot
this guy can't i can't i already see
what this is i see what he doing let's
see what he doing
is this this is a narrative xbox can't
afford to be happy yes yes i agree it
just can't
like it just they don't have that you
know if
like you said cog we had had the big
first party game right the show
right now something whatever showcase
what the machine could do
with no caveats no this falls to the
wayside
i have that so it's like no absolutely i
agree with you shout out to let me get
the chat they kill everyone
shout out to bg sample size you killing
every other salute stop correcting my
bronx lingo if i can't say antidote or
correct
all right don't become we from the bronx
you supposed to know i don't get
all the words tell the truth shane the
devil have your playstation drop yet
has your playstation crashed yet tell
the truth that's all i want to do just
put yes or no
i told y'all about those herniated
playstations bro it's only those
i haven't heard anybody with a digital
but how many people that we don't got to
do this already yeah
it is a universe so it is you know we
we're gonna move on because clearly
we're not gonna convince
king otherwise based on these multi
plants what's going on in these streets
he has his own theories as to what's
happening here we go
the funny thing is i i don't yo go back
i don't care
like i'm good all these games are
getting on xbox anyway right because
he's about
that's my third party platform factual
future
fix it guys expect just fix the issue
yeah because
this is the worst thing you can have now
the worst thing is you're joint brickin
is you can't play your thing and you're
gonna send your thing back to get
another thing
that's the worst thing the worst thing
is not
oh i don't have a television to see what
these dudes is talking about
but the worst thing is you got a
television and your joint ain't working
don't worry about what xbox is doing
over here you
so let's get the y's first otherwise
don't give up maybe the playstation
needs to go where i was for two weeks
by the way brother so happy you're out
of the hospital yes
bro yeah man glad to have you with us
brother
oh wow all right let's hold on did we
read all the xbox baby uh
right did we get tony bryant follow
super chat xbox basically playing pc
ports right now
why his back compat is clear abandoned
side before you know we did that um
by choice oh yeah i'm seeing them now
okay uh game watcher is king you are the
man but i think you're definitely
dancing on this one
xbox created awesome hardware let's pick
up the right tools to show
its power i just gotta point this out
real quick for you continue yeah
uh everybody said i need k i i
[Applause]
let me get that i got that siri it says
file switch the series x sdk
is a soft launch but yeah we did that
okay we did that okay just want to make
sure we got that
yeah that is true you you honored
something with that
the sdk was a soft launch for the um the
xbox series x
that was in june so now they do just
getting the real launch right now
they're gonna bust your cheekbone open
so
be careful it's going to live in flame
too back there with that living flame we
hold on we got to make sure that we
didn't miss these
with the 5 super chat question why are
people worried about 120 frames per
second
when the ps5 don't have a native 4k60
camera
so messy now we're leaving this yeah
because i see let me get it i i see
we did the picture with the g then i see
um sliver flying to us which are great
guys relax playstation 5's are bricking
anyway hashtag
book of x and we did that we did a game
about choice
yeah okay yeah we just have king duvey
now with the two dollar super chat
i'm too scared to store more than 2k on
my playstation 5.
yeah i feel you man because if you you
know
their memory is short yo yo like i said
knock on wood
yo christopher heart quick can you do
120 hertz on your tv
that you're putting dance moves in there
why don't you dance your way down the
best box
yo shave the devil this man right here
take a picture of your tv do it 120
hurts yeah 120 hertz isn't vr
it's not the same no it's not it's not
anything but look we think it is
anyway moving on you know king
smith one more sorry spinning swimming
with the five dollar super chat have you
heard the new mixtape called damn my
joint don't work by psi
it's like no rest mode can't turn it on
ass like the book of acts
yo he got so many caveats that dude told
me don't lay it on its side while it's
breathing
that's another thing yo i don't think
anybody should be laying either of these
systems on this side
i think that's a lie dude listen i don't
know the only thing i'm doing right now
is no rest modes
no rest moves i'm just saying that yeah
i'm down there yeah that's like
you got to power down can't really say
anything about this yeah anyway no this
is real quick
um anyway so this is your topic um we
have a few more oh still coming
here we got jake gamer by choice with
the five dollar super chat
xbox is bad about giving people
narratives to use against them
it just seems xbox runs a great race and
then runs into a rake and breaks its
nose
they're good at getting people to use
narratives against them because they set
explorations and then later on it
doesn't meet up to you that's the thing
and
the thing you get as someone because
they don't say anything right and at the
end of the day
it it benefits them not to say anything
right
so we uh we got bg with the five dollar
super chat
question why are people worried about
120 frames per second when the xbox
don't have a first party game written on
period king yeah you know what's bg
you're definitely on to something you
know we should
we should have dug in the crates and got
an old five-year-old game
too from you know the playstation 3 to
shine it up and spit shine it and throw
it back into the street
oh we should've got a dlc that we put
for the playstation 4 and spit shine it
and put that on um
oh wait a second oh we should have put
some free game that we got inside the
back catalog that's inside the bushes
and we should have just ran with that
acting like they got games stop playing
with me
[Applause]
i would tell y'all right now for those
of you who may be new to the podcast
yeah not hurt
this is vintage this is vintage this is
king that we've known for 30 years
kids okay you if you you have to be
ready
get ready for me they don't understand i
will take your joint forward smash it up
and bring it right back to you so
basically king is saying that
spiderman's dlc
and we know it's a dlc because i
finished it in five hours now tell me
something so basically that
you're you're imp are you implying i'm
implying i could have kept my
playstation 4.
wow wow i can't go there i can't go
i'm going there i'm going there because
i got the same experience why
why you gotta control 80. one more
element appeal with the five dollars
destiny will be ready with that 120
hertz update with real
uh with the real ask update yes yes that
crucible 120 you already know
so we good we good yeah we're good all
right look we got to move on these two
we'll
fly through um yeah so let's get your
topic i'll frame it for you man it's a
good topic um
lg man thinking of tvs god last season
you know what i'm saying so lg looks
like they are teaming
up with microsoft into a partnership to
promote the lg oleds as the next-gen
gaming experience
together and again this partnership is
going to be official partner for xbox
and europe
africa middle east and asia pacific not
north america i believe they have the
samsung
partnership there but um expect to see
lg oled tvs using xbox events and shops
throughout the regions
and said the companies highlighted the
hdmi 2.1
feature as well as the low input lag vrr
auto low latency mode so all these
things and pretty much they want
they said xbox series x will be the
first game console to support dolby
vision plus atmos
came into an update next year so very
very
powerful partnership it seems with lg
which right now looks like it's getting
uh we're known as kind of like the
definitive next gen tv to get
so king man this is you you know what
you thought did you brought this to the
table man
yo so so so two best tvs in the market
two brush brands in the market
xbox got them on lock here we go
all right if you want that premium
experience if you're over there
okay boys you gotta get a real boy
call me now if you're in the okay or you
feel
if if you happen to be overseas
what happened for you who do that who do
that for you
who do that for you you don't know you
don't know who you don't know
lg down with x-box
so what happens if you in the states and
you like that samsung butters
you like that 120 who down with that
xbox
nobody buying no playstation sony
televisions in the bushes
nobody even talking about those tv so
when dudes talk about next gen
they talk about lg and they talk about
samsung right
so when dudes talk about next gen they
talk about xbox right
they don't talk about playstation 5 and
they don't talk about no sony television
so that's just letting you know exactly
where they are at
they are in the bushes with their tv and
that big box to keep bricking on people
so listen you like the new companies the
smart companies companies that are
actually vying for your dollar that is
actually moving the industry forward
like lg and samsung and just get an xbox
oh my god
king is smoking uh yeah that's uh some i
should get addict i don't know how he
feels about this so let's get
it quick quick i don't care all right
move it off
[Laughter]
what's up about the partnership sir
listen man like uh
the lg's everybody's talking about the
c10 everybody's talking about the c10
that is a beautiful move to get in bed
with them right now
um because those tvs are only going to
continue to improve like i said i was
waiting because
i want to see if we get 12-bit panels
next year i don't think we will
uh from what i've heard of the leaks of
the new tech that's coming down the
pipeline we're not going to be quite
there with 12-bit panels we might not be
there for
a couple of years actually so i may find
myself grabbing a c10 uh
soon to because and i don't know what
we're going to be getting
in next year's tvs is leaps and bounds
for what we have now
except for what we've been talking about
before
this capped 48 frames 48 oh yeah
we talk about it we got to talk about it
and the thing about it is this right
when you have the when you have
bandwidth that's open at 48 gigabits per
second
that's a tv that can handle a 12-bit
color chroma sub-sampling right
i mean the thing is if we don't have a
12-bit panel you won't be able to show
it
but it still is better to down-sample
that 12-bit color to a 10-bit panel
than not having that right wait wait
what what did you say again
you you talking about the hdmi um hdmi 2
inside the xbox where
it's um what is it again it's 40 right
there what's the what's the playstation
shout out to vincent from hd tv test i
believe he don't know if he caught
itself
where he he had did the cable test and
it looks like it is big um
the hdmi 2.1 cable looks like it's being
throttled
i don't know what's the word the brake
taking out turbine
it's just hard y'all the playstation
cable is full 4k
120. it's it's it's oh excuse me 8k it
is a two-point
it it's so the thing is that for
whatever reason the bandwidth the
bandwidth right
right yeah they can hang it up there
like that
it was an update there was an update
that actually upped the
the lane speed to 12-bit because at
first it was that 10-bit attempt
actually over the 8-bit for a second and
then they updated it and they got it
back to 12.
playstation 5.
that's ridiculous it's one of those
things this is like
did there's so much like technical stuff
that goes goes along with this or
whatever
yeah um at the end of the day though
what you do want
um and the xbox at its core is is kind
of capped at 40 as well so
when we get to the point where we you
want to have something that has
with dolby vision support coming soon
dolby vision does have
the bandwidth to give you 12-bit color
right and like i said
if you can have that 12-bit color go
through and
down sample to 10 bit it still looks
better than
than pure 10 bit right right so it's one
of those things that with the xbox the
xbox also has that limitation where if
they can't open up that pipeline and
give you that full 48
you're not going to see that in its best
light right
so it's still a lot of stuff a lot of
weird stuff there and it was kind of
brought on i think in part by lg
limiting
um the bandwidth on the 2.1 on the t10
they decided well
rather rather than which the c9 had
right the c9 had
remember i was speaking to blaze yeah
yeah yeah so the c10
now what i i don't know personally can
that be rectified with
assault the software update that's the
question right i'm not sure i have no
idea
yeah oh i hope so that would be the case
because then
when we do get games that are supporting
adobe vision right
look out yeah look at me who does that
who does dopey vision i mean i just need
to know
what like what gen what next generation
console does
you know damn well look he said look out
i mean i need to look out for it so
which which which console does that so i
can look out for it i'm gonna tell you
this though king you might have to
give up on your samsung if you want no
no no no
that's that's not that's already done
deal but i'm just i need to
i need you to answer that question who
who who who i need to look out for who's
doing this
sir yes xbox oh xbox is doing adobe
oh oh that's next-gen oh okay
anyway move it up get my balls up we
gotta get out of here um
actually but um yeah look the same thing
you know i thought it was a really cool
partnership i mean obviously right now
lg's kind of
the the c10 is being known i mean even
we had we had jason ronaldo on he had
put a tweet out in reference
to the c10 as far as being kind of like
the de facto tv that people are
flocking towards for uh next gen so
salute to them for making that deal
overseas that's a good partnership i
like that
you know kind of like that in market and
then um like you said the hdmi thing
and to me i think the thing for me is
the vrr because i know there's a lot of
the issues right now with the tearing
but if you do have the lg to see you
throw that vr
your valhalla ain't doing none of that
you know what i said so that
that part is kind of cool sucks that
only the one percent can experience this
you know the majority don't know and
they're getting the terry but if you do
have that tv
it is a cool feature so salute the vrr
and all that stuff so we are going to
move on unless we got any super chats
uh no i think we caught a hold of a
second let me make sure i didn't cut
them out
mm-hmm just make sure we're good because
we got uh actually uh
oh we got stitch with the 20 super chat
get him king
get him home there we go
sports announcer man sony has been cold
all game three seconds left so many
dribbles between the legs
and puts up another brick the book of
acts oh hold on
i gotta get vg though he said y'all
gotta celebrate features of the small
wins
he said you don't got no games you hate
to see it you hate to see it
i mean yo you know what that is true we
got to celebrate any way we can
because you know a lot of times our sony
brother in the crying so we just got to
listen look over at until it would be
like yo
it break the game bro it break the game
again
how many times you gonna go out with
that girl she gonna keep breaking on
we gotta pick something dirt dab has
announced the patch for the series x yes
like we we knew this we knew it's coming
down
i mean like how many times do you pick
up your controller are you scared is
this gonna be the next time like
will you be able to finish this part
right now
so we got up yeah we're good with club
all right look this is the big one man
let's set this thing up right give me
one second
y'all let's take it back to the old
school hang out for a second just for
solving the win again
[Music]
i'm picking everything sovereign pick
everything's sovereign pick i'm picking
everything sovereign picks
this thing this sauce and captain what i
want the cat
one second but if not it is what it is
hold on one second let's see
oh there it is display cache let's get
screen 2
please we're going to make sure that
it's doing the right screen
you're not clicking the right thing you
have to click the display capture double
click it
properties oh my man there we go there
we go other monitor
please there we go and then boom
and then we are going to
so we are working our way two game of
the year yeah yeah we're gonna work our
way to the jungle to the joint right
quick
and um let's bring this over
let's do that okay there we go so we're
going to do it for now
the thing is this year so i gotta bring
you on your actual screen too like the
google hangout so i can look at it
okay
all right so you know what time it is
it's crown your lord y'all y'all know
what time it is you know what we're here
for
so soft i have to ask you this because
um
every year we do this um we do game of
the year i believe two points right
where everyone was one that's how he was
doing it yeah
really i didn't remember that yeah yeah
that was game of thrones too
okay so what i want to ask is it's up to
you and we don't have to do it
let's pick who goes first and see one
last year
so the thing is do y'all still i want to
ask the
roundtable like do y'all still want to
keep that or do you want to up the
stakes more with with game of the year
like maybe three points or something
i'm cool too but if you guys want to do
i mean three three could really shift
things
right or wrong yeah like it'll be that
that's it because if you get game of the
year right i feel like you should be
rewarded but i just want to make sure if
y'all were cool
if i want to keep the two i don't know
all right cool three is good because i
could
pull somebody in into the win like you
know what i'm saying like
don't know so obviously you know the
rules we're not doing the east uh the
what you call it the the
personality yeah esports i'm sorry
unless y'all want to do esports
games nope nope okay so i don't want to
do this debut game seems like the first
one
yeah so we're gonna start it that's the
best debut game
so we're gonna get to it crown your lord
we're gonna tell yourself you're gonna
be able to tally
up everybody's joining i'm not doing it
right now i'll just go back in
okay cool all right so this is what time
it is best debut game
choice is all looks carry on mortal
shell raji and ancient epic
rookie and phasmophobia
asthmaphobia yeah all right let's start
attic which who you got who's winning
this
phobia okay i really like carrion but i
think phasmaphobia
king no i won whatever
okay all right oh man i i'm gonna go
carry on i'm gonna go carry on here i'm
gonna
count i love carry on too but i'm going
with something all right we're gonna
skip content credit again no
personalities we're not going to do the
personnel all right
best multiplayer for outstanding online
multiplayer gameplay
and design including co-op and massively
all right this is rough so choices are
look animal crossings
among us call of duty warzone four
guys ultimate knockout and valorent
who is winning best multiplayer attic
uh among us it's off
i think at the end of the day i think
you still i think it's still war zone
[Music]
oh wow you went was over who lose this
year
all right king kick fall guys
that's a strong man you never even
played that game
no i don't but if i hear enough chatter
from something from people that i don't
even play the game
and all i hear is about the game how hot
the game is from
every single person that touched the
game i don't know i think it might have
some influence i want to go for god or
among us
yeah among us i'm scared that animal
crosses is in there though
yeah that's kind of weird but i don't
think i don't think because i don't feel
like animal crusher shouldn't win but i
got like i feel like
too long ago and it's the type that type
of multiplayer is really just
like like sharing your island yeah
one of those is definitely like i'm
gonna go home that's my favorite zone
um
to the panel thank you sir it's a little
silly people bring it to the chat you
know
put your stuff down yeah all right so
let's get sports best sports and race
again hate the fact that they put it
together but anyway
dirt 5 f1 2020
fight for 21 or nba 2k 21 or
tony hawk's pro state of one and two
well we got at it
what not one first last time king goes
first this time all right king of course
what you got
mba go with the nba all right solve
i say tony hawk
tony hawk too
shout out to bg for giving me a copy of
that totally wrong
let's remember who votes on ninety
percent of the vote
comes from from you know industry people
mm-hmm
is is actually just you know the
whatever fans
yeah i'm gonna go i'm gonna go with tony
hall only because i feel it should be
mba 2k but i got a funny feeling that
the
power is that me that way i'm going in
all right
best sim strategy crusaders king
desperados three gears tactics
microsoft flight simulator and xbox
chimera i got to go to attic on this
first
that's substrate that's our genre wow
i ain't played it but i'm gonna go with
my gut and say crusade kings three
because i want to say
no i'm saying crusade king's three
crusade king story for 200 please
thank you alex oh soft what we got
crusader kings wow you're really going
with this girl
no i listen i listen to a lot of
podcasts
okay up that's why anything last of us
is good that's getting my vote anything
last of us gets my vote right
i feel like what are we doing
flights on him you know what
it says strategy yeah
there's no greater sim than that flight
sim i think i'm going with king on this
only because guess tactics and x-com in
my heart
but i know they're not going to win i
know they're not going to win this is
not a full-fledged x-com
gives tax is good start but it's my it's
one of my first ones but i don't think
but simulator did hit different did not
get a 10 shout out
yeah we gotta yeah i'm gonna fight
someone i think this is what microsoft
got a legit shot
i'm gonna go there even though your pc
your rig better be serious best family
all right animal crossing new horizon
crash bandicoot
four guys mario kart live home circuit
king
minecraft dungeons and paper mario the
origami cake let's start with king again
i'm curious
four guys um you said best family
best fam the best game appropriate for
family play irrespective of genre or
platform
yeah i'ma say
what you got animal crossing yeah i
think i'm leaning
yeah i'm gonna switch mine
he gonna switch yeah
family i think this is the one for
animal care yeah nintendo family no
nintendo family because i think four
guys of them might get the multiplayer
stuff but king you ain't going
home circuit you with capping for home
circuit you ain't go
home seriously no i'm not doing that
he's trying to win
that channel you get that super chat
from clutch man um
let's man with the five dollar super
chat we will not have it we we
will we not have an industry icon this
year or was that academic
just saying there are a lot more
pioneers of gaming out there
savage oh you know ridiculous
best fighting for the best game design
primarily around head-to-head combat we
got
grand blue fantasy versus mortal kombat
11 ultimate
street fighter 5 champion one punch man
and under night in birth exe i'm setting
it off i'm going straight with mortal
kombat it was amazing
aftermath dlc i'm riding my motor combat
on this y'all addict what you got
give me a second i'm looking at the
metacritic oh my god
this man doing metrics
oh my god he do what we really do he
tried to wait what are you doing
i think the thing about mortal kombat is
that they took it out of evil like it
was i don't understand
the narrative around this going out the
box
nah you should trust your guts
just hear me out saul i i'm hearing from
you know
people that's in that community that
street fight is hot
the workforce man you can't go wrong
only one it could be for hardcore
yeah like that's the only one that could
be hardcore fans so consensus mortal
kombat all right
anybody talking about some other
fighting game
best role-playing game final fantasy vii
remake
i just want to state that persona
doesn't deserve to be in here
i don't know i i like persona but it's
literally just the game with
with a couple extra dungeons and an
extra character yeah it's literally an
expansion
fair enough dension impact
persona 5 royale wasteland 3
and yakuza like a dragon vegan
let's always saw first yeah i got it
come on man i'm going for the w final
fantasy vii remake
that came out already on xbox oh my god
[Laughter]
okay what you got um gangster
guess it
wrong shot with this shout out the heck
that uh loads of gaming shout out to
stitch
follow super chat final fantasy 7 is not
a full game why is that demo in here
he said that yo
everything in me wants to say final
fantasy
but it's not a lot of character
customization and they say in here
player
character customization progression and
that's not really in final fantasy 7
everything's pretty much set besides
like seven
weapons on every character i'm gonna say
where he slammed three and i'm probably
gonna lose this donor
the 8.3 is an actual it is good
it is it's really good i want to say
persona and i think prescott is probably
going to win this
but in my store i can't pick that game
final 747 not a full game but still
longer than most full games so what's
the problem
i'm riding with me that is true it's
longer than miles morales
yo stop
listen man my heart would love to go
with addict but i'm trying to win
final fantasy 7 rebate baby let's do it
because i'll be honest i think that's
the only shot they got when they get to
the game of the year stuff
and if final fantasy in my opinion is
going to win this is the category they
got to take
games so let's go all right best action
oh let's get into it best
action defensively with part two last of
us two valhalla
go sushima miles morales ori
will of the wisps and jedi fall in order
from last year this is
heavy in the streets competition lost
song
start with you first i think jedi hates
it
really i think i think jedi takes it
just last of us
it's too divisive last of us is too
divisive or we got shafted for game of
the year
i don't know they might give it to or
because they got shafted for gaming
best actually it could go to mine was
too as well though like
um west accident combining combat
travertine puzzles why would they
specifically say traversal yeah
you know what i'm going with miles i'm
going miles really
on the serious note i can literally see
this going to any one of them i can
literally see a scenario with any single
gamers can win
but i'm going my gut because everyone is
deep throat in the last of us too
so i'm going to step right on that plate
and say last of us too
even though i feel last of us too is
definitely fantastic i'm gonna go with
jedi falling order
because i think they're trying to right
or wrong i think so too king i think i'm
with you because look
ghost is my heart i won't go and win
this but
ori should deserve too man ori really
deserves this
damn and last of us is a heavyweight
distance remember last year they
they they skipped out on um fallen order
yeah and uh
i think i think this is the i'm going
i'm gonna go with king i think this is
the
the the apology that what you call it
yeah
yeah there'll be a copa yes all right
that's what i'm going best action
doom eternal hades half life alex
neo2 and streets are rage 4.
mistakes can be made do maternal for
five thousand
i've got that doom no doubt no doubt
hades wins every categories in hades
whoa you talking reckless now there's a
lot of characters kind of hades is it
hades
what is chess okay what are we doing
mistakes can be made
in hades for everything yeah he said
he's gonna win he said hey
did you hear us off he ate you're
best action um i'm gonna go with hades
that's the flavor of the mall i want to
go with my heart but i know damn well
streets of rage ain't winning this
[Laughter]
i'm trying to i stay losing my heart
so i got a fraud but what i don't love
oh i to me it comes down people are
sleeping on alex though
but is this is there a vr category i
gotta find out this is this vr category
all right so yeah
so to me it comes down to doom
in hades damn this is hard i'm going to
go do them
only because i think hades deserves to
win but i think there's other categories
for it to win and i'm going to give i
think they got to give doom something
so i'm going to go with them there
that's what i got all right innovation
and accessibility
assassin's creed valhalla grounded
hyper dot last of us two
and watch dogs legion
um
this is where they do it innovation
recognizing software and hardware that
is pushing the medium forward
by adding features technology and
content to help games we played and
enjoyed by even wider
audience that's what we lost
they made this category before that yeah
i think this yeah well
i got to hit with kate because it's king
you go hard body karate for last of us
uh um the whole innovation and
accessibility that's the last of us too
um
i felt it was more accessible than last
of us won
i think the concepts that they thought
about was realized
to perfection yeah and i think it
reached a broader audience with this
unapologetic uh portrayal of certain
characters
and the mature themes so definitely
it's a talking uh yeah accessibility
last of us shout out to kai boss for the
chat last of us too their
accessibility options are insane one of
the rare console games affiliate yeah
and to me
i agree this is the de facto slam dunk
last of us too has to win that
so we gonna move forward best vr ar
that's where i come in
dreams i'm just gonna go straight to it
man alex i'm going with alex for the win
for 20.
i think it's dumb if anyone doesn't say
it i'm going as i'm just going i'm not
even going to sugarcoat it where we
assault
alex all the way okay alex
yeah i mean shout out to bill stilwell
shout out to a lot about vr guy
like they cannot stop talking about alex
that's all i hear about shout out to the
gene
all right best community support this is
going to hit my heart
um playstation um vr uh i don't
fix it i don't no it'll break that
everything up exactly
thank you for clarifying that sir i just
was asking questions
why my vr is in the bushes best
community support
this is a touchy one attic we might get
in trouble that's what we this when we
go left attic
but alex apex legend destiny 2
four guys knock out fortnite
fortnite domain sky and
valerie attic what are we doing
i am sticking with my gut and saying
they're going to give fall guys this
because
they're just going to get fall guys like
i want to say destiny
forte is stitch they mad if they like
you better say dusty
i want to say destiny but like i said
earlier i want to win
recognizing the game for outstanding
community sport
transparency and responsiveness
inclusive of social media activity and
game updates
and patches that is this award fall guys
ultimate knockout
for 100 no doubt
so i might have to go with any addict on
this with the fall guys because it's
like
they're not gonna give it to fortnite
again even though it could it very well
could be fortnite but
i mean that this marvel season has gone
on forever and it's like
i haven't necessarily continued to add a
bunch of stuff to it it's just
marvel season no man's sky man they
really turned that game around
guys i think it is of the moment like
four guys at this moment is not what it
was when it launched
but they really they really barbie wants
to try that valorent because that that
our valley is going to
get you know okay
like zip said four guys literally only
had one update
it's tough it says all of them as a
whole and not just one and not just
[Music]
that destiny in there
for tonight
fortnight the these are the split roads
these are the categories we lose the
reason why i say fortnite
is um travis scott
[Laughter]
yeah concerts
travis scott i mean who they made this
category for these dudes like who has
the best community
support they're like yo we thinking
about uh doing
lego something and then next week is
lego something
no no they're the only ones that flip it
on a fly yeah they don't care
is there a party is there a party game
category there may be i think they may
be here
you know what i'm gonna move to fortnite
then yeah listen my heart says dusty but
they they're not gonna win this
they're not gonna win that um you know
where i really want to go
but i'm scared to death i'm a sucker i
don't want to put my name on it
i really want to go no man's sky i
really want to go no man's sky
turn turn around on that game is
amazing and i know dizzy here a lot of
people
but i think i know i know all right i
don't care
if you if you if you fix something but
it took you three years to fix it
you haven't heard people being like i
don't care like they
they took forever to do it and people
actually care like
it's not like people are mad at them you
know what i mean like
the vibe around it isn't negative the
problem is the king is right though
is that damn they dropped that marvel
update they dropped fortnite drops so
much damn it they do they do whatever
they want to do when they want to do it
and it's like every week they can do it
is the community happy with them i see i
don't know about that that's the thing i
don't know if the fortnite community is
like yo
they ain't leaving true yeah i already
been to new york
to um you're right you're radical on
that no no no no
beat me today yeah we lost many battle
royales to him um
to be honest last of us was more
next-gen than anything i've seen on
either of the next-gen consoles absolute
salute
all right so we gonna move on i'm going
for tonight put me down for that best
mobile game all right come on among us
call of duty mobile games and impact
legend of i don't even know what this is
rune terror and pokemon cafe mix
the mix of the cafes
i'll go last because i gotta look up
this list oh my god
this man doing extra credit homework keg
what you doing
um best mobile game yeah
wait a second gears pop is not up there
they discontinued it sir
i'm playing it right now i'm literally
playing it right they're gonna
discontinue whatever they want
that's not a category sir we have to
move on
whatever then um whatever whatever
sovereign says
oh my son what are you saying
he's put me back piggybacking off you
i'm going to see
among us is that thing that everybody's
talking about playing whatever
but in terms of the quality of the
product i think a lot of people really
like genshin so um
that's what i'm doing i'm doing good i
think this is where gen shin can win
i think this is the one i'm going
against you all right harmony connor
wants to go with that pokemon because
pokemon's always pokemon but
i ain't even looking that up um
best engine all of you go for ginseng
it's okay for me to go okay
it's okay best indeed this is tough
carry on
four guys haiti spelunky two
spirit fairer let's go with the
champions
this is the thing though like gets me
right because they
obviously if i'm gonna if i feel this
game of the year
then my family should be should be best
indie as well right
you should pick hades just because you
create hatings for every category
wow a lot of people like that spirit
pharah
oh that's a good game you know what
though i mean
flat out it's got to be hades
[Music]
everybody deviating off of hades 80s
yeah so we are we are in conjunction
here
moving on best on going
game oh this is rough come on now
apex destiny call of duty
fortnite no man sky let's go
you know what
this is the destiny category come on
king you want a ring count
i want a recount if i lose i want to
read king come over
certified king we do this we breathe
this
i hear you you're trying to kill me
oh my god
they keep putting this dude up here for
some reason
they keep forcing them into the club
this is where saul beats us on emotion
so i gotta hear where soft is gonna go
you know why is it why do i feel like
it's still fortnight
say fortnite
i'm trying to think of it no no no uh
no reason no reason to these industry
people after
you know after voting for them like you
know the chance that king is order
something
why they keep putting i know that chad
is loving king right now
you know what i'm a rockford king i
think i i think they have to give they
have to give no man's sky
so it's roses somewhere right yep
and like the turn around this game i'm
gonna go with king no man's sky did you
pick cognac
right now right there
if the category is best ongoing awarded
to a game for outstanding development of
ongoing content that evolves
that is literally destiny like this is
no that's literally no mess
but they they was in the bushes for mad
life and they evolved
out the bushes they haven't walked out
listen to you right now don't
except if found kentucky route zero tv
edition
spirit i'm gonna make my vote in spirit
of error tell me why
and through the dog sometimes i've heard
a good thing oh man
yeah that through the darkness i
remember i heard a lot about that i
don't know
it's either tell me why or spirit fair i
brought up with spare photo
yeah it's very fair for me i'm gonna go
with tell me why tell me
that's a good game that's good oh god
adam tell me why king let's go
oh yeah remember that tell me yeah tell
me why they got that game up there
i'm gonna tell you why they gonna win
tell me why we about to link win because
we picked tell me once
what you guys did you got to tell me
about you yes i got time all right
all right oh here we get into the bitty
gritty now now we get to the
cook up best performance
ashley johnson as ellie laura bailey as
abby king
sakai logan cunningham as hades
and najib jeter as miles
morales this is i think i think this is
gonna be the minority uh
cake i'm gonna hit you first this is
gonna
affirmative action pick
this is the affirmative action picture
you know you have to know how much he
was really messing with her about to
lose this one
yo he was going body nah nah she's the
greatest thing since life's bread
all the way to the death i know you ride
it i knew you was doing this i i knew it
but i need solve i need to know what the
chat
is i'm riding with abby
i think regardless of all the vitriol
she got
like she nah man
performance is crazy over everything i
still can't bring my ellie play that
game again
over ellie i wasn't i mean i can't bring
my ellie's was great but i
really disliked her a lot of a lot of
that game like yeah
in a way that i didn't dislike abby so
no doubt
i gotta ask because you're very
controversial with that game
where'd you where you at i don't know i
know this is this has got to be tearing
you apart because you like
all these games but pretty much all
right confirmative action i
want to see that middle one that's what
i know what i would love it but
but i want the w
and i gotta pick different ones from
solve
at one point of time and i said i'm
gonna pick last of us all the way so i
gotta roll
with ellie for the win oh
[Music]
oh you really breaking off okay shout
out to kai he said ghostbusters still on
release okay
let's i want to you know god know i'm
cherry blossoms but i'm trying to win
and the sad part is i did who said it in
the chat
zim yeah he said his performance was a
little flat certain parts he was flat
yeah it's got i'm going with king i'm
going with king
the abbey thing is just too much in
these streets shout out to jd game and
20 likes of chat just dropping a little
support for these lords while collecting
all the respects for these sony fanboys
talking about power and xbox about
having games when the narrative changes
again in one to two years with new tools
and studios salute salute jd gamer
look this is going to be i'm looking
forward to this category because best
performance that's tough
all right yo and we no one mentioned i'm
telling you
i know hades i heard he's amazing this
anybody could win
if someone picks if no one picks hades
and it wins hades then i'm okay with
that
best audio design let's get it do
maternal
half-life alex ghost of sushima resident
evil 3 and last of us 2
recognizing the best in-game audio and
sound design oh man
what are we doing who's who brave enough
to say these first
i'm i i gotta go with alex but i don't
know how many people
even though i don't know who played alex
it's like i told you it's like i told
you and i said i think
ghost or last of us is winning this one
of those two
doom has amazing audio
but doom and last step is the last of us
so all right gotta stick to my guns
and go with last of us
i gotta go last of us when i hear they
shot tommy
i'm sorry i'm sorry i gotta go with that
good told point that's nice
to put the positional audio like the the
cocking of the gun like all that stuff
that's cute
the wind blowing and ghosts oh that's
cute but did anyone play that no
so on his ghost is amazing i know yes
you know no no no no so i'll pick that
it's okay i think that's gonna win
so what's your final choice sir ah damn
it give me a second
look okay i can't pick the cherry
blossoms again
even though i want to i'm gonna lose
they're not gonna beat this is too heavy
um yeah it's gotta be last of us
like you said hearing again i'm playing
about playing on facebook ps5
hearing the sound stuff and the
individual call out
it's a very revolutionary title a lot of
things they're doing there and i think
the reason why i'm going to go away from
alex even though it probably deserves it
is that i think
they're going to win their vr category
and say okay we gave you
we got you you know what i'm saying
don't say that let him lay
all right that's like but solve is
waiting on me i'm trying to let's solve
goals
[Applause]
until i go
[Applause]
do maternal final fantasy 7
remake hades ori willing to win
for outstanding music inclusive of score
original song and or licensed
soundtrack addict i'm going to you first
because we're going to fight if you
don't do the right thing
you pass all right king king doesn't
it's not disemotional about this one
okay no ori let's get oracle
i wanted to say or we could win this
attic are you coming back are we going
to start
i want to say either last of us or your
final fantasy
no
but at the end of the day it's still old
stuff that's redone
like yeah that's true too
chef
come on you know what it is you're
trying to get me to lose because then
you're going to pick left let's die
together
let's die together okay you go
first final fantasy i'll go with the two
let's go
me actually i mean i mean hades is crazy
but i think it's it's out of order so
yeah already deserves to win this too i
can't
we can't or he definitely deserves to
win this there's no doubt
yeah i mean king did you vote i can't
remember yeah he said that's it
okay so moving on moving on so we always
got there we got that all right we get
into the big boys
best art and direction final fantasy 7
remake
ghost of sushima hades ori
last of us part two for outstanding
creative and our technical achievement
in artistic design and animation
hurry ori oh you got ori
okay uh king i'm last of us too
man i'm torn uh solved i'm waiting i'm
passing us off
you know what i'm changing last was part
two unless those parts your
direction i see i see that i see the the
the way glass it was part two
artistic design and art damn it
look at ghosts because ghosts are cool
directions fire too
yeah but the animation
ghosts you can't pull his pants up his
legs what about orion
beautiful game but is it last of us no
it's not
so ori is going to come away with
nothing
let's just all agree to pick last of us
so none of us lose
no well ori did or he did when um
what you're gonna call it best audio
i don't know i can't remember anyway
no i just said it did yeah
last of us last of us yeah i'm gonna
have to go last of us
i mean when you talk about like just the
gun animation
yeah very relevant if anybody's looking
to purchase xbox series x
i mean s it's available right now in the
microsoft store mm-hmm
okay series x no the s
s yeah we got to get uh we got to get
these guys over we got to get screaming
to move
all right look best narrative let's get
to it 13 sentinels
final fantasy vii remake goes to sushima
hades last of us for our two kick i
know where you go you i know where you
going best
okay outstanding storyteller thailand
and i'm gonna tell you that story and
the way that is told is
beautiful but last of us takes a
defecation across
all these games and leaves it in a way
that is crazy i gotta go laughs but i
don't care i'll die on that hill i feel
like i know you
it's all my mom i'm doing it man
sometimes in life you gotta take a stand
i hear you you gotta take a stand and
i'll never forget
speaking of my man addict and he said
did you get to the end of goes to
sashimi yet
and i said no and when i got there
oh boy and listen i know last of us
could win this i know
i know this is the one i have to ride
for ghost storm
i got to i i think that it's underrated
it's criminally underrated
now final fantasy remake could win this
too because we
all know those who ended it it did
something crazy
this is tough hades in there i don't
know enough about 13 sentinels
i heard 13th sentence narrative is
amazing all right that's amazing you
know it's got to be
anything that's here is amazing for a
reason i got to take a stand
i'm going to ask him because goodbye my
stamp
is that i feel that even though last of
us should win it they was very divisive
with a lot of people
and a lot of people were divisive also
with final fantasy remake so i'm riding
with the ghost baby i'm going to college
go
cherry blossoms up throw them up which i
got
i got hades
haiti's narrative the way that thing is
told like i said you don't you don't see
narrative like this in a roguelike
and it's it's genuinely a great story
i'm going to hate his addict what are we
doing
it's hard for you it's hard i feel this
is your a lot of your things
in here
you research your metacritic
is he in the bushes is he even here
he's muted
what are we doing who picked watts oh he
said who picked what
we saw with hades i went with ghosts
king is last of us part two i got to go
with with the the winner of last year
i'm gonna go ladies
oh my god that was hades okay follow the
chair
best game direction final fantasy 7
rebate
go sushima hades half-life alex
last of us two again the heavy hitters
song when we do it awarded for
outstanding creative vision
and innovation in game design direction
and design
i gotta go with half-life here
i think half-life it doesn't get the
doesn't get the burn that it should but
it really is
it is the killer app for vr yeah but it
came too late to make vr the thing that
people wanted it to be
that so it's the killer right for vr and
that's what's going to win
best vr this is so
i don't even know i got a pass i gotta
pass what you got okay i mean i'm attic
i'm going hades that's game direction
okay
king ladies
yeah i might think i'm michelini i mean
this is
vision but last of us could win this
last of us can win this too best game
direction
you know what i'm going last of us
i'm going to break free for real a lot
of people had a problem with the
direction in the game that's why i
really said
i know i know i just feel no i feel you
i just i'm i think the innovation part
is the part that's getting me okay
that's why i'm gonna go there all right
here it is three points this is it y'all
know what time it is
the big boy game of the year
last of us two i already done king is it
no animal crossing votes for king hades
goes to sushiva
final fantasy 7 remake doom eternal
addict and go live okay
solve returning champion three points
this could break this can break at all
for me it's funny because it's between
two games right obviously
hades and the other one you'll be
surprised mm-hmm ghosts
you know why why which ghost has had
despite my feelings on it
and and similarities to other open world
games
there's been a lot of press that really
loves this game and then you
add legends on top of that i don't think
you're separating the two
oh you have a compelling package that a
lot of people like
um but i'ma go with hades that's right
you do that
you stay yo you stay yo behind right
over there
y'all know what time it is y'all know
who i ride for
and soft said it best complete package
you know i'm riding with the sakai throw
the cherry blossoms up all day this this
is going to be hard i don't know if
they're going to do it
but i'm dying on this one all right it's
going to be hard
i've got yeah yeah the complete package
nothing more i need to say
um attic i need to know your answer sir
i want to say animal crossing
but the reason i was the animal crossing
is because i would win the bed
mm-hmm and fortunately says yo
is the only game that can win he said
it's adam he said book it that's true
here's the thing y'all
we got to say this forte animal crossing
has to win
something it ain't winning game of the
year i don't think we've
we've gave animal crossing any love on
any category
none of that he trying to steer you the
wrong way at it don't listen no i'm just
saying
it's not winning game of the year you
have a family game
mm-hmm slow-mo says soft must want to
lose to choose hades for this
let's all pick i'm leaving over there
he's locked this game of the year is the
last of us too
i feel that i feel that attic you have
that i closed the playstation 4
generation i feel that boom
that i i just couldn't go i like last of
us too
so many people were disgusted by that
ending like yeah
and they had to play it i don't disagree
with you though but i
such a fantastic game it's the complete
package
but we're talking about the anderson
you're going traitor let me see who who
said it in the
um who said it in the uh chat was an 83
mega critic
oh man they're being disrespectful if
the press love
ghosts they whitney gave it at 83. i
feel that look i know
i don't know what it's up against i i
know you know what i'm saying
um yeah i mean but i will say this
people's adam crossing could witness
oh and we could all be mad so you going
with
what at it last of us too lies to us too
all right we got the votes are in ladies
and gentlemen that is
it crown your lord will return
you know what i'm saying once we uh this
one's gonna be interesting this is gonna
be
a very highly competitive situation man
we'll be live streaming yeah we would
definitely be live streaming that man
you already know what it is
get out of here fun little debate with
the lords how we do
all right with new our people with early
comparisons of third-party multi-plats
such as assassin's creed valhalla
and dirt 5 showing to perform better on
playstation 5 than the series x
how concerned are you with the initially
perceived power advantage the series x
was supposed to have
choices are a very concerned
playstation 5 may prove to be the easier
next-gen console to develop for
b not concerned most devs didn't receive
their dev kits until june of this
year or c stop
damage controlling when your tcl don't
got vrr
to see that's great tearing right
we know where kings going we know we're
kicking i figured king might go that way
so i put that in there
[Laughter]
shout out to those it was making the
vote yo shout out to lord thor that came
through man salute
you know what i'm saying dog castle x
the statue community
it was super lit man yo thanks for
rocking out with y'all
the whole thing let's get these outros
rocking lord addict where can the five
people find you what you got going on
sir
i'm eating i'm skipping my intro this
week pizza
no doubt no doubt lord solve the return
of lord son
let's go yeah man i'm just happy to be
back i'm gonna be playing some video
games this week thank you
god sir i take some time for myself yeah
it's funny because even lady sob is like
so she she knows like leave me alone for
a little while please
that's what's up you already know so you
gotta get his gaming all he's got his
new consoles you got both of them right
you got both
yes he's good to go
lord king amazing craving statue and all
the smoke today we're going to finally
find you
you can find me on twitter laughing at
these dudes with these tcl's
talking about 120 hertz baby 120 hertz
baby
you know the playstation us they don't
even have a playstation all they got is
games
they sitting there waiting for the
playstation to show up you know
when the soft launch is off i'm beyond
i got your playstation upstairs and i
don't care and i played it and i ended
it and i'm not doing
nothing to it until next year that how
does that make you feel
that i finished the miles morales in
five hours
i'm not touching that playstation again
until some games
ever come out for the thing so that's
next year
how does it make you feel that you want
it so bad and it's sitting in my house
doing
nothing sad and i'm playing my xbox
salute for the best always
yo much loved everybody that pulled up
today a lot of show we got some more fun
stuff
coming towards the end of the year and
eventually the end of um
what you call it uh 11 a.m eventually i
don't
can't wait to
but yo salute man we got some more fun
guests and things going on
anything anybody i got to say before we
get up out of here nope
all right man everybody we will catch
you guys next week
peace
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
um
[Music]
you